you have officially two weeks left to
get dripped out it's time to do the
drip get your aparri merch right now
using that link in the description down
below if you want to get dripped out
like us the boys and get your official
trash taste aparri merch now is the time
to do it because you have two weeks left
look at them look at them stand up boy
stand up stand up they're actually color
coordinated this week look at that look
at that
how do i look we have the bright ones we
have the dark ones we're actually like
don't want to take it off you trash
taste or trash taste after dark you
decide look how [ __ ] cute this design
is guys isn't that so cool
the embroidery is super high quality
yeah look the cat sleeping is actually
so adorable
i remember when i first saw this i
needed to get this also apart did such a
great job because it looks like our sets
yeah it actually does one for one it's
crazy last time we had a print design
but this time we went for embroidery
because we want this merch to last it
costs a little bit more than our
previous merch but we want this merge to
be around when you are 90. so your
grandma who is 90 they can stay combined
but seriously the merch is super high
quality and it will last so when you get
it you get it for life you become one of
the boys for life exactly unfortunately
the first thousand special postcards
have sold out but you will still get a
personalized message on your postcard
when you purchase one of these but again
you only have two weeks left later
so go down to the link in that
description below and grab them while
they last because until 2022
these will be around but after that it's
all gone you better end 2021 on a high
alright after the episode
so there is going to be a couple of
things in this figurine special episode
that uh we won't be able to show on
youtube we bought hentai figures yeah we
did and more and a lot more a lot more
like crazy [ __ ] that you're about to see
or hopefully not see so if you would
like to see the full uncensored version
of this episode and support us in the
process then make sure to go over to our
patreon patreon.com trashtaste link is
in the description below but uh yeah if
you're on patreon you can enjoy this in
full if you're on youtube you can still
enjoy it but just without just a few
little things there's a few things
overall it's the same [ __ ] all right so
don't leave you just get less pixels you
get it you get less pixels but go over
to
patreon.com and enjoy the episode
boys before we start we have to have to
lovely asmr
special version 2
is now alive
sorry sorry completely just uh
interrupted you there connor figure
special bigger special
figure special it's happening everyone's
in
everyone's special everyone's been
waiting for it it's the figure special
that's why we're cracking open a cold
one let's cause it's finally here
we had some wait more than a year
because we had to wait until akihabara
opened up people getting vaccinated and
um the country letting us finally do
this not even a global pandemic can stop
us from wasting our money on anime
figures well cheers boys here's to a
successful cheers
cheers cheers
how does it feel to be in presence of a
winner because that's going to be me
today
honestly honestly i'm just i'm here for
the content i can't wait to show you
some of the stuff that i bought
stop being a good sportsman for one
second and talk trash all right well no
that's how you lose haven't you learned
from the past special so if you don't
know there are three videos on our own
respective channels where we went to
akihabara and spent three thousand three
hundred and thirty three dollars each a
total of ten thousand dollars between
the trash table which is where budget
which is where the clickbait comes from
we're like we're like we can stretch
this out to ten thousand dollars so we
can put it on the video title
and we have various challenges at those
stores that we can we hopefully
completed and we'll talk about on this
episode of the podcast but we have no
idea what each other bought we don't
know how many challenges we've completed
and uh yeah today is the day where we're
gonna find out we have an idea about
what the other boys did but if you want
to find out now before you watch this
then please go watch all of our videos
or you can watch this first and then go
to watch the videos kind of like
watching the avengers end game and then
watching iron man either way either way
we'll either watch all of them
now or watch all of them after i would
say watch all of them before but that's
just fine yeah but they're all up right
now and they're all down in the
description so check them out yeah yeah
and also on our main channels not our
second channel yeah
so basically we're gonna just kind of i
guess run through the products uh
there's also overarching challenges joey
do you have them all of the the
challenges that aren't for the store
they're after they are they are on
screen right now we're not going to read
them all out we've got 16 of them yeah
we have 16 of them but uh i think what
some of the notable ones that we
remember are like stuff like buying a
figure closest to the price of 420 and
also
as well
of course of course
i'll be honest i don't remember much of
the other challenges i don't either so
it's gonna be interesting yeah because
by coincidence i remember
like in the first tour i completely
forgot we had overarching challenges and
it was only in the second store that i
started to figure out well we we all try
to go for the 69 one right i think we
all try for the city
yeah yeah that was uh that was
interesting it's a lot harder than i
thought it was yeah so how did you boys
feel going into this challenge compared
to i mean my challenges that i got at
each store were way easier than last
year which is good so i think i i have a
better chance this year
it's really up to you guys really i
think i think god though got like some
of the harder ones
i just kept getting [ __ ] this year man
which is why i was just like you know
what i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm just gonna
content the first time that's how i felt
last year
and this guy got an easy road again for
the most part for the most part i think
hard challenges i had to find a
a figure from an anime jerry had watched
do you know how hard that is
i had more like finding the the needle
in the haystack
like what are you what are you
this whole store full of anime and jerry
hasn't seen a single one i think uh it
was interesting though because we went
to four stores again this year um two of
them were ones that we've been to
previously which was a stop and army
army yes and then we had two brand new
ones which was rasheem bun and mandarake
yeah and uh i think the new stores were
definitely a challenge because uh yeah
because
it added some spice into the mix because
we didn't know what to expect so
especially ending on mandarake it was so
much risk came into what was in
mandarake because i
hadn't been to akihabara for about a
good year yeah so i literally had no
ideas what would be in any of these
stores right yeah mandarake is truly
like the needle in the haystack store
where like you go in it's it's the don
quixote of [ __ ] things i've found the
coolest stuff in mandarake oh yeah you
also don't find a lot of stuff in
mandarake yeah it's it's either all so
i'm glad we had some variations yeah
yeah exactly there was a store that sold
everything some stores that didn't sell
anything
uh some stores that uh had a lot of loot
stuff so that's good yeah yeah but i
mean i was i was kind of nervous kind of
wasn't i
it was weird because this time i wasn't
thinking about decorating as much as i
was winning yeah
i was like i don't care about decorating
the office [ __ ] that yeah it's all about
winning by the way if you if you're
brand new to trash taste the the figures
that you see uh on the backseat are the
stuff that we got last year yeah yeah so
so we only had a budget of 500 last time
and they got us all this
uh so we like we we
what was it six times yeah seven times
the budget now six topics sex top with
the budget i almost believe that the
saying of like constraints make uh the
what
what did you say i was like i have sex
this man this man is the oldest one
that's why i tried to not say that
instead i said six times
it's like i completely i think almost
having no limitations well there was
limitations the money was you know but
three thousand dollars is a lot yes more
than one person will ever spend so i
feel like having no limitation nearly on
what you could spend almost made it
harder yeah yeah because you felt like
okay i can buy literally anything now
yeah because before is that you would
see a 500 figure yeah and it was like
well i can't believe that was my budget
yeah yeah exactly right you can't buy it
so i almost made it more interesting now
you look for them like the most
expensive figure in the store and you're
like okay this is like a sizeable chunk
in my budget but it's not i'm not going
to be dead in the water even if i buy it
yeah let's just say we didn't find a 3
300 figure
there was some stuff in mandarin
okay yes that was definitely like one
figure would have gone our entire budget
yeah but for the most part it definitely
felt like a big difference from last
year yeah to this year right because a
lot
like it's it's a difference between like
being a student and having like a
disposable income that's what it felt
like man you know
just thinking about some of the [ __ ]
figures i had to spend money on yeah i
know
no because i remember last year i
remember going to a store like a stop i
was looking at figures and like can't
buy that can't buy that can't buy that
and now this time going into a stop i
was like what can i buy let me just let
me just buy it all you know even the
most exciting i'll take your entire
stock yeah and it was like i'll go i'll
take everything from here to here yeah
and it's like a dent in my body trash
taste season one versus trash day season
two the peasants versus the kings what's
next it's like who can buy out all of a
stop first
yeah i actually like got to a point
where we got to mandarake and i had
trouble finishing my budget yeah because
because there was like mandarake had
some really really cool [ __ ] but the
really really cool [ __ ] was too
expensive yeah and then some of the
mid-range stuff didn't even make up the
budget i had left because originally
there's like no in between yeah
originally i thought uh we had three
thousand dollars to spend
um and then only halfway through did i
realize oh no the entire budget was ten
thousand dollars so technically it's
three thousand three hundred thirty
three dollars
um so
so i had to like make up 300 more which
i didn't think i had in mandarake yeah
yeah yeah um so yeah it was overall very
interesting yeah it's very tough yeah it
was it was a long day as well my god
yeah it's definitely a long day for sure
it's great it was good fun though i
really enjoyed it i really i really
enjoyed it is it exhausting having to
run around stores for hours a little bit
but i it's not nothing i haven't done
before yeah in season one
exactly i definitely felt a lot more
comfortable filming this one than i
didn't see yeah you seem like you're
like kind of digging it more yeah i
remember i remember when we were all
filming our intros i had to get away
from ghant because it was actually being
too loud like morgues now he's like
what's up guys it's me gigger
you spend 24 hours
in russian
he's gotten too good we've created a
monster he's just too good over youtube
flashback to season one occupies special
encounters like
how do i say [ __ ] without a script yeah
because i remember when we were filming
season one you boys had finished for
like a good 10 minutes filming your
intro yeah and i didn't think i'd even
started filming yeah because i'm like oh
cindy uh am i looking a girl yeah
what
[Laughter]
the glow up man it was it was it was
great to see we all did a much better
job actually i think
yeah i hope that came across in the
videos yeah you know hopefully they look
better sound better and the energy's
there yeah yeah although most of the
time i did get distracted and i was so
focused on doing the things that i
forgot to actually talk to the camera a
lot of the time i was just so intently
focusing on finding these goddamn
figures that i didn't i didn't think to
present right now i would like to hear
even though you should go too long i
would like to hear all of the the
overarching challenges because oh sure
i'm sure i think it'd be good for the
viewers to know what challenges to keep
in mind
can you stop reviewing so these are the
ones that were separate so tell us how
much point you get from them as well
okay so one point to whoever spends the
closest to three thousand three hundred
and thirty three dollars and thirty
three cents to the budget uh one point
to whoever buys the most expensive
single figure okay uh the one with the
cheapest figure however loses one point
okay
figuring from the lowest rated mal
series gets one point okay uh the most
figurines bought overall gets one point
uh most spent on one series gets one
point most spent on a non-figure gets
one point most spin in one store gets
one point so there's lots of
room room to wiggle okay uh as we said
earlier whoever spends the closest to 69
on a single figure and whoever spends
closest to 420 on a single figure get
one point each
we're counting that as six thousand nine
hundred yen or four hundred and twenty
thousand forty two thousand yen uh
figuring from the highest rated male
series however loses a point that's
that's the normie point you'll use
uh if anyone bought a hentai figure
that's a point because uh you know god
forbid you're going against you
monetization i totally forgot i had that
too
uh i've just
remembered i bought
i just said me too
let's just say someone got a point for
that uh one point to the most figures
bought from an anime original movie oh
okay so you know any like shinkai movie
movie anything like that uh minus one
point for every funko pop obviously yeah
uh minus one point for every duplicate
character anyone buys and minus two
points for every exact duplicate figure
anyone buys oh i see so we made that
like stakes high because it's like you
know we might you know say for example
gan and i might buy and a stolfo figure
you would lose a point but
joey's a massive stealth of course but
there's like lots of the stuff i figures
right from like different makers so if
it's the exact same which i don't think
will happen honestly from the massive
budget we had then it's two points lost
uh and then the final one is if you fail
to spend at least a minimum of 50 000
yen at a store or 500 you lose a point i
think that was the one we were all kind
of paying attention to yeah because i
use that as like a good way to gauge
the rest of my budget yeah that would
encourage us not to hoard all our money
for one store yeah yeah exactly yeah and
uh just just if we didn't make it clear
how we are converting we got we're gonna
be saying everything in dollars
but that's just basically taking the yen
price and dividing by a hundred i don't
know
it's not exactly right but yeah yeah
that's that's exclusive it's the closest
you'll you can think of it
i guess we should start with the first
store there yeah
so the first store was slashing bun
which is what we wanted to go to last
year as well yes but unfortunately we
couldn't get approved one time yeah this
year since we knew we planned ahead yeah
yeah okay a huge huge shout out to uh
geeks plus for actually sorting this out
like last year last year uh melin sorted
it out in like five days or something
before we were going to film this time
we had they had a bit more time but
everything went smoothly
like like three weeks or something this
time yeah we learned a lesson and like
most of the stores a lot of stores we
went to we got to like have free reign
over them without our customers which
was fun as [ __ ] yeah that shimbom was
great especially because we got to go in
before the store even opened so yeah so
move whole floors to ourselves just like
going to legoland without anyone there
yeah like [ __ ] like awesome
younger means dream yeah honestly
and you've you've lived out the dream
this is this is actually an actual dream
right like this is the [ __ ] you wake up
as a kid being like i have infinite
budget to spend in this store and i can
buy anything
oh
and you have to buy a figure that we
chose for you one of the stores gone
it's great yeah yeah brilliant so do you
guys remember what your challenges were
for this store so yeah i've got two
challenges for this one i remember i got
[ __ ] immediately um so so we actually
actually knew what challenges were in
trash taste good do we have trash taste
good is is he weird
sorry i kept calling him
trashbox trash boxing so we actually
knew the challenges this time because we
didn't know them last time and we picked
some easy challenges and some harder
challenges uh that would be harder to
complete you just killed trashbox yeah
my god hillside
and uh i started off with some of the
hardest challenges what were your
challenges got my challenge was one
find an anime figure or find a figure
from a game that conor has played now i
play a lot of games
now now normally this would be easy but
we're talking about akihabara yeah
famous for selling anime figures and
maybe jrpg figures you know um a lot of
japanese ips
uh it was basically games that connor is
not so well in every store there was
multiple games that i had played so if
you've got this in any store you've been
fine yeah yeah yeah did you pay
attention no there was a lot of time
that was just a big one there was a lot
of turn-based rpgs a lot of story-based
games yeah i went through
um and then my second chance challenge
was find the most expensive figure in
the store and uh buy it oh yeah that's
right if these boys found a more
expensive figure
then you don't get the point then i
don't get the points easy that's right
and what are your two challenges joey my
two challenges were fairly easy so my
first one was buy a jojo figure and make
the same pose and i mean you know
georgia figures it everywhere especially
so that wasn't easy given the second one
i had to kind of uh you know use my
thinking cap a little bit it was i had
to buy a figure that can beat goku
and i have to not only buy the figure
but i have to convince these two boys
that this character can beat you and the
audience you've got to talk
i think i figured it out though i think
i figured it out i won't be easily
impressed in fact i might even be
argumentative about it wow it's almost
like i'm on trash
my two challenges were buy a not anime
figure yeah which is very difficult
which is tough in
uh yeah it was uh because a lot of the
games either had anime or animations and
i knew that you guys would be [ __ ]
and that if i bought something that if
it wasn't anime but had some animation
yeah you would give me [ __ ] right um and
there were shows that i thought didn't
have animes that apparently are getting
animes and i thought geez [ __ ] um
and the other one was uh just pick a
figure blindfolded
oh wow okay so i just span around in one
section so that one's not tough it's
just it could end up very badly it
didn't end up great okay
it didn't
we'll see okay we'll see then okay all
right so wait how many figures did you
guys buy in lashing bun
three
three three all right same here three
okay we started things off like for me
lashing man had so many good figures
yeah right it had a lot of high quality
figures and aside from mandarake it
actually had the most expensive figures
that i could find yeah it did yeah which
uh [ __ ] me over obviously
well on that note then go on what is the
what is the most expensive figure
okay we'll go we'll go for that last oh
okay
okay so we don't know any of the figures
that each other bought i got glimpses of
one or two but i overall i don't know
what you guys purchased and i hope that
you guys don't know what i bought not
gonna lie because russian was so early
in the morning and i was still like in
the waking up process i remember half
the [ __ ] i bought it rushing
well i only bought three so it's really
easy for me at lashing bun like i spent
all of my time trying to complete my
challenges right so i like i didn't even
consider the overall challenges i even
forgot that we had overall challenges
because i was just trying to like i used
up all of my time completing every like
my all my challenges because i remember
the store was like opening up the
general public and i was like rushing to
get my figures onto like are you rushing
man
okay that's not funny
maybe million laughs though
of course melin would laugh
all right well yeah i remember joey like
looking at me and he's like oh you
haven't got your figures yet and i'm
just like no i completed my challenges
in like 10 minutes yeah yeah mama pretty
easy and the rest of the 50 minutes i
was just perusing because because both
of them had me looking around a lot so
the second challenge which i did second
um which was after perusing around to
try and find the most expensive figure
was trying to find a figure from a game
that conor has played well why don't you
tell the story while introducing the
figure yeah okay well which one do you
think it is okay well i'll tell the
story because the figure is not actually
that big right because because i had the
most expensive figure challenge i tried
to go on a budget at this point because
it was the beginning of the day and so i
look around i look around at what
figures are available with dashing band
i look around there's final fantasy no
connor's definitely not played final
fantasy
is it is it really it doesn't have you
played final fantasy vii no you haven't
you haven't i don't know i haven't
finished it
i'm sorry i wouldn't count that
when wait the remake no the original
what you've played the original final
fantasy vii i got like 10 hours in and i
quit
what
what
years ago
i actually don't believe you how have
you never mentioned this before because
i didn't finish it
well you've played it yeah i've played
it you know the basic concept of it yeah
why have we never talked about this
because i didn't really like it that
much
wait so you've owned the ps1 no no it's
on steam
yeah so you've played it in your adult
life uh yeah when i was like 18.
what
yeah
it used to go on like steam sales all
the time
oh my god wow that was literally the
first figure i stole and i i know that
was the first figure right
if you bought that i didn't i didn't
beat it i didn't mean it i didn't read
it but you played it yeah it doesn't say
you needed something oh true
yeah yeah so so like mostly i looked
around on the second floor and i didn't
notice that there were arc night figures
on the second floor until people were
talking about it yeah i don't know
because i saw archives yeah i had such
little time that i spent so much time
trying to buy the most expensive figure
that i just like lost all my time so i
didn't see any arc like figures um and
then i went downstairs because all
basically all of the second floor were
like expensive gaming figures which are
just like basically fate and final
fantasy which i didn't know that you
played all right so that would have
played fate
yeah i know i know i know you haven't
played fakes
um so i go downstairs and uh i don't
really see much it's again it's mostly
anime figures
um and then i see i see a shelf
and it's all persona and i was thinking
i was saying to myself
i've been trying to convince connor to
play persona for two [ __ ] years and
it has led up to this point and i was
pissed that connor if you were a good
friend you would have taken my
recommendation and started playing
persona 5 but no one time i played
persona your house for like 15 minutes
does that count i don't know if that
counts
i
what happened was i was watching uh
sydney go around some uh like it looked
like a digital maze or something mentos
no no it's one of it was one of the uh
dungeons all the later dungeons
give me the control i'll do it the loss
and then i got lost too
sorry it didn't really help wow yeah i
spent a good 20 minutes so technically i
have played this wow yeah i haven't
played it much but yeah okay so come on
come on but then the third one i saw was
a mega man one and i've connor's never
talked about mega man before right i
don't have you ever heard him talk about
mega man i've talked about mega man on
the show and i don't think he was like
he's never mentioned it but like but
like i saw mega man and i'm just like
mega man seems like a corner game you
know it's it's it's like it's like i
could see connor playing mega man
there's a platformer it's a shooting
platformer yeah yeah yeah like you used
to speed run cuphead right yeah yeah
yeah exactly but like but like i didn't
know
if like
did you own a nintendo i what what is
your game console history because like
that this made me question what your
game console history was because i'm
like you haven't played final fantasy
because you don't own a ps1 i had a
nintendo 64. i had a nintendo 64. my
parents took it away because they
thought games were evil yeah and i
managed to convince them to get me uh
ps1 i broke then i got a ps2 and i got a
gamecube and a wii
then an xbox and now pc most of the main
line consoles there yeah so i remember
so i didn't think connor would be old
enough to have like a super nintendo or
nintendo and like where else you play
mega man apart from the old school
consoles right pretty much um so have
you played mega man because i didn't get
it not like fully i've played it at like
you know like friend's house for like a
few right like no i've never like
committed to sit down and people yeah it
is a very
[Music]
i'm an xbox kid and i'm like okay xbox
like gamecube era i'll stretch it out
and say maybe he had a lot
of this figure man
and then and then sydney came in clutch
and was just like gone how can you
forget literally the most
successful franchise in the [ __ ]
world
how can you forget the one that's
literally right in front of your face
literally the most successful franchise
in the world and it's a tiny figure
because it's a pikachu figure okay
220 yen
and i i got this not forgetting that
whoever gets the least expensive figure
um
i might have just [ __ ] myself over by
uh earning a point and then losing a
point uh otherwise i would have got
something more expensive maybe you
should uh keep track of that because
that might very much be a contender yeah
that's fine that's an okay thing he's
definitely i mean i mean i know you've
po i know you've played pokemon uh we've
talked about it several times and even
if we hadn't talked about it i could
like you could you could bring this to
like
90 of anime fans or just people in
general they probably would have played
pokemon yeah there's also cyberpunk
overwatch a bunch of other actual was
that cyberpunk
ones yeah was that one one on the first
floor or second floor second floor both
a lot of the games are actually on the
second floor yeah right yeah also uh i i
me and connor found a bunch of apex
figures uh at army
i i walk in i turn the corner first
thing i see is a jojo figure so uh who
is in there because i was
oh
joseph okay young joseph young joseph
that's another oh it's a lottery figure
it's a lottery it's an a prize lottery
figure of joseph jones that's a nice
figure let me see that let me see that
oh that's good i was going to say i also
bought jojo figures from here and i was
hoping you didn't get the same character
as me yeah i hope not otherwise you're
going to lose a point who knows
i did that
all good yes joseph it is yeah it's
really cool
are we unboxing these stuff oh yes
let me let me let me unbox this pikachu
figure
careful now that's a lot of value
probably these are a pain in the ass
when you open the box yeah now you're
going to be here
i'll open the box yeah since we got on
the topic of persona 5 i'll show you my
personal favorite oh my god there you go
hell yeah okay i couldn't i couldn't not
get this because i i for one i mean
center five is my favorite job the whole
time this one open you should we cracked
this one open yeah wait so how much was
this one then
this well let me see uh
so here's the question would you have
considered buying this figure if this
was last year because this was like 82
bucks yeah so this uh so the joseph one
is
eight thousand two hundred and fifty so
eighty two dollars yeah and this persona
one is two hundred 200
wow okay
two hundred dollars this is a really big
box for what doesn't look like it should
be this big yeah right yeah well like
this is the this is the persona 5 the
animation persona one
technically an anime figure
what's the difference between persona 5
the animation figures uh it's about the
main it's that the main character his
name is
oh
in the game
he's main character he's his main
character [ __ ] yeah he's joking we live
in a society
sorry to uh any audio listeners this
week um plastic asmr
why'd you get the most plastic thing on
earth jerry
how many turtles are gonna die for this
figure
all right
you're gonna have to like help us and uh
all right nabi and ashley uh this is
this is gonna be this is gonna be the
big difference between last year and
this year is that now we have uh oh [ __ ]
i'll
yeah we want to keep the boxes
oh okay okay that's a clean joseph
that's clean as [ __ ] yeah right so was
this the pose that you did outside oh my
god no no i did i did the standard
joseph post oh okay yeah it just said do
a jojo post off that do you hate your
poses okay i i thought he said do the
same jojo pose and i'm just like i don't
i don't think joey did these questions i
yeah yeah yeah yeah okay is it on camera
is it on camera yes are you sure you
want to talk about specifics it's not
going to come to bite you in the ass no
specifically
okay okay all right
we're being nice yeah i would just watch
your back if i were you being nice
okay so this one's got like a full like
well [ __ ]
joseph she's very top-heavy
he's kind of like rohan where like you
uh oh he's uh
let me have a look at this judge
everyone jerry sets up this persona one
oh
this is quite the nice figure i wonder
why it's okay the thing with jojo
figures is i've learned basically a jojo
figure expert at this [ __ ] point um
jojo figures are weirdly expensive
sometimes
i've bought some so there's a certain
line of jojo figures that i don't think
are that impressive yeah they're
visually they're not that uh
appealing i'd say
and they're some of the most expensive
jojo figures as you'll see cause i
actually bought some of them myself yeah
um it's weird and i don't really get it
um
so i guess it's strange but this one
normally when they're like this they're
pretty good the ones that move for some
reason are like triple the price yeah so
if you got like the shittier version of
this and it moved it'd be 200
he's just like hi i'm uh oh
i'm generic main character
yeah
there we go there's someone around
my brain isn't working
are we keeping all the figures bruh that
costs 80
he's so top-heavy he's he's built like a
brick [ __ ] out he's joseph's
[ __ ] joe star dude
i gotta say he's holding glasses his
stand is very very big compared to the
figure
like the the uh
the circumference of uh the stand is uh
very big
there we go
who did you uh first romance in persona
five joey i don't think i've ever taught
you about this uh obviously the best
girl
hell yeah hell yeah oh my god bro you
think i'm a pleb who would say futaba
yeah [ __ ] out of here thank you
literally
okay and i did second but futaba is
literally the worst goal in any persona
game thank you oh my god i say this and
like people try to crucify me you know
people who say they like futaba and
persona 5 are the same people who go to
maid cafes all right
it's literally the same type of person
yeah that's right i called you out
i'm trying to figure out where the chair
goes like futaba's the type of girl who
would say pogba's out loud you know what
i mean like why why would i want that in
my life i don't i don't understand these
jokes but funny you you should play
persona 5 and you'll understand
you would know if you played persona 5.
yeah
um do you want a cheers in front of one
of my challenges or a generic video uh
which one do you want to do first
none of them none of them why they're
all pretty all right they're all pretty
all right okay i'll do the jojo one
first then all right
okay oh jelly nice but look at the price
what
it's two hundred dollars for joy
why did you bring a 200 figure of jolene
i didn't want to spend much money in the
store and i wanted a figure and i needed
one that would put me over my bud over
the 500 minutes oh this is a sass as
well they're usually like rather
expensive so these are the ones yeah
super action uh statues that's the one
you can move these ones are always so
expensive and i don't think they look as
good as the others
oh and lie i think that jonathan one is
cooler than this jelly one yeah i mean i
can i can take it out but
it's just
and this is opened and it's two hundred
dollars i don't know what this would be
what makes them that like much price
it's the hype of part six the hyper part
six yeah i'm not entirely sure
there were a lot of expensive jojo
figures these are the expensive ones
like or that that figure line yes yeah
the sasses are very expensive the
movable figure lines for some reason are
quite expensive jojo uh maybe a figure
expert
can tell me why out there i don't really
know maybe maybe it's more difficult to
design figures that move it could be
yeah there's also a lot of like movable
parts as well i think that's what it is
but like i feel like with removable
figures i feel like the static one
static ones actually generally i've
always said this i prefer static i i do
too i i i don't want to think about
posing it i don't yeah i despise the
little pieces that you have with it that
you can't put anywhere where do i put
them i just i just with the essay this
is i just don't like the the joints
having like
exposed and then you look like it looks
like an angel because like whatever pose
you have you put with the movable
figures it's never going to be as cool
as
one like this with like a static pose
maybe this one's cool because jolene it
comes with like her extended hands
oh that's kind of cool
i haven't seen that before so perhaps
this is quite a unique one because
there's like
she has extended fingers here
but yeah i suppose two hundred dollars
though
god damn
that's that's a big span
it's the same as this yeah
sorry i know like i remember i remember
i thought like when i first walked into
the store when i was doing like my most
expensive figure challenge i thought the
most expensive figures was going to
going to be around 200
because that's what i could find at
first um so knowing that that's 200 i
think uh yeah what's your most expensive
figure
we'll get to that oh my god he's [ __ ]
teasing us of course of course true
youtube needs a clickbait right
so this is the second figure that i
bought uh so this is
this is from one of my favorite artists
yum
uh
yeah
so if you didn't know yamu did uh miru
tights and he has done the art for
another anime that's coming out this
season i believe which is uh gun buddy
probably shouldn't have that on the
screen for too long oh [ __ ]
yeah oh okay i
okay well i'm gonna i'm gonna keep it as
static as possible so mudan has an easy
time censoring this we get it it's it's
a it's a very hot figure um so let's
let's
see this out so
i didn't actually know that uh his
characters had figures
so when i saw this i've never seen that
either actually yeah cause like i don't
do you count this as a hentai figure i
don't really count this as a hentai i
mean yomo is a hentai artist if it's not
from an anime and it's inspired by like
a hentai artist but he has he has made
but he's made an anime mirror tights was
an anime it is his anime and i think his
ganbare doki chan yeah
i think that's the second one where it
like focuses
on office girl workers yeah um and i
think this is clearly has these uh
fetishes just put straight i respect it
what i'm saying is he has amazing art
stop cocking us show us the figure i'm
trying to okay this is uh this is going
to be the first of many lude figures uh
because because you had sydney yeah
unfortunately having sydney as a camera
woman um i'd i'd like i'd sometimes just
wander off and then i'd look behind me
and she just wasn't there and she'd just
be like filming this lewd figure and i'm
like sydney
i feel so sorry for alan because he's
got a like
he's got to censor most of this
oh this is nice yeah that's nice that is
very nice and that chair is like nicer
than the figure
holy [ __ ] it's just nicer than the one i
have at home
dude i want i want this sofa look at
that put her on look at that
all right okay i'll give it to you
that's pretty [ __ ] hot yeah that is
like that i like that that's hot oh
that's hot
next to the pikachu is the funniest
thing i've ever seen
but like the duality of man wait wait
how how lewd is this
that's not too bad the box the original
art is definitely yeah yeah
well i say like he is a [ __ ] god when
it comes to drawing
it thighs like you're moving like a
stonehenge-esque thing on the tail when
you move that around
honestly this uh yeah all right that's
pretty good it's pretty good it's pretty
good all right nice that's nice
all right oh wait wait you're not going
to show the most expensive oh you're
going to show that now oh do you want me
to show it now joey
okay we got a canada figure from
akira this i think was the most
expensive thing what was that connor
what was that what was that
well you don't like it no it's fine it's
fine
did you also get
because i'm pretty sure i saw connor's
life flash before his eyes when joey
took that figure out all right how would
you pay for this
uh this one i paid uh
20 275 for this one oh yeah i didn't say
how much i paid for the yom figure
figure i paid
um i paid
what is this
120 for this oh that's not bad which is
pretty weird
yeah i paid a hundred twenty dollars
like a three hundred dollar figure yeah
i know right
damn that's really good i think i i
think i got a good deal
okay i haven't actually seen the inside
of this but uh oh it's one of these
right okay
it's like it's like the old is it like
an action figure yeah it's like an old
school action figure oh okay
one two six yeah i saw it because like
you know i this was at the point where i
had already bought the the joseph one
and the one that can beat goku which
i'll show after and i was you know i was
i was having a good time i was like this
is the start this is the first one i'll
peruse find something cool and i found
this and uh i couldn't not get it
because yeah i love akira because uh i
was going to buy some akira figures and
then i kind of realized joey's
definitely bought an akira figure not
gonna lie i completely forgot about the
whole like duplicate yeah
uh so i was like you know what
what i i forgot wrong
no because i remember you're the only
person who bought an akira figure last
chance no no no no no that was gone oh
that was connor was it you yeah it was
me okay i just assumed it was joey yeah
where's the yeah there's the canada one
right oh was it you i bought this one oh
okay this is extreme it kind of looks
like a kendo doesn't it
right there it looks clean though that
does look clean yeah let me let me pull
why don't you hand it off to them and
they can yeah yeah assembly they can
assemble something yeah all right what
is uh what is your next one connor um
well
what is that you just [ __ ] chuck that
on connor i don't really know um so what
do you mean you don't know you bought it
it's native
creators collection
illustrated by
you don't mean to attack it though
why does that name sound familiar
well jerry because it's a hentai figure
ah
so do you know what it uh looks like
i do
[Laughter]
did you have a look at it no because my
challenge was to open a figure i sorry
choose a figure yeah uh blindfolded oh
this oh this is the one this is the one
i chose blindfolded which which aisle
did you go in to like oh clearly he went
into the mailing
i think or maybe we both chose to go in
the hentai one i'm not sure yeah let me
know yeah look look inside of a [ __ ]
can i say
can i [ __ ] help
let me see let me see
all right turn it turn it around slowly
so mud has an easy time uh centering
this jesus christ connor
[Laughter]
let's
if this is on the line that is that is
definitely over the whole the whole
thing is on show yeah that's uh that's a
full display again i didn't choose to
get this figure
i need a closer inspection oh [ __ ]
unsensitive looks weird oh so it's under
the desk that looks so weird dude do you
know what's weird about copper do you
know what see do you know what's weird
about seeing hentai figures it comes
with an optional moaning face okay oh
hell yeah it comes with an eye here oh
let's go do you know what's weird about
himself figures it's the fact that the
[ __ ] coochie is unsensitive yeah it's
not pixelated as [ __ ] yeah i was like oh
yeah that's what it looks like so how
much detail is there on there way too
much
it's a lot this is this is
yeah wait unless you can take this off
is that is that removable i don't know
well guys it looks really well luckily
it's uh no this is
so close that's a
[Laughter]
that's what i'm talking about i don't
know what this hand is doing
guys what oh sorry sorry sorry sorry it
goes on the desk
i don't think that's how that works
i don't know if that's how that works
yeah on the picture it's on the day oh
really like this
oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah sorry
uh if you're on a patreon enjoy if
you're on youtube sorry that this is all
blurred but
i'm wondering what this looks like on
youtube is it is it going to be blurred
or is it just going to be the black box
it's a black box or is it going to be
like the white glowy thing no it's not
done choose carefully
is it the white bars
i'm taking this off now yeah that was
two hundred dollars oh my god you know
so you've spent two two hundred dollars
for it's totally that two two hundred
dollar figures yeah well i had to make
sure i
reached the 500 minimum i mean was that
nothing you just wanted to buy out of
like your own volition i was so focused
on the challenges because i had one that
i struggled with which we'll discuss
right next time afterwards money will
span iso
you can take you can take that one home
i'll take that one home [ __ ] yeah dude
all right gun what was your most
expensive figure that you purchased okay
so
what was the most expensive figure that
you guys i don't know you know what you
bring yours out and then if it happens
to be more than the one that we found
then you get the point
okay well you know what
i'm going to go out and say
no no no no no no no no i know i didn't
get the most expensive figure
so what was the most expensive figure
do you think are you saying that uh the
amelia one was the most expensive one
that you found i thought it was that was
seven hundred dollars that was seven
hundred dollars yeah is it nice i found
a more expensive one
i actually took a photo of it just for
proof yeah in the meantime
what the [ __ ] gone
all right that's
gone that's not a figure where are we
gonna display that
you have to go through here
you have to go through here
so obviously i had the most expensive
figure store and to tell the story of
this one as well so my first instinct
was of course to go to the hentai
section because you know sydney aside
sometimes the most expensive figures are
the hentai ones they are they are pricey
as we've said
yeah yeah as we've just established and
i saw some for like 150 dollars at first
i was like oh that's pretty expensive
200 oh okay now now we'll get into the
territory 250 all right 300 okay
and then i went into the fate section
where dreams died because because of
course i did where dreams are made where
dreams are made by lawrence
and holy [ __ ] i found so many good
figures and like some of them and like
as you're about to see with this one
i've bought
like at which point do we not call it a
figure and does it become a statue you
know
bring it on out i mean i see it in the
corner of my eye but uh it's pretty fun
so oh my god
what the [ __ ] god where are we gonna put
that so i'm gonna kind of like
can you even see me anymore over here hi
so i found a few fake figures i don't
know if you can even see me right now i
can't hear you gone over the [ __ ] the
monolith slab in front of you so i found
this for
500 and something bucks 150 dollars 550
dollars and i was just like there's no
way
i'm gonna either take it off the table
or open all right all right can uh can
can one of you guys open it
someone's gonna i'm gonna need help
cracking that boy open it's literally
like a fancy action board that's so cool
though oh that is pretty cool it's
actually like made of like felt yeah
okay so i found that and i'm just like
yes i have found the most expensive
figure in the store and it's a figure i
want because
that that's not a figure because that
looks [ __ ] amazing that's a statue
that looks [ __ ] amazing and i'm like
i want this yeah and then i turn the
corner and i see this amelia figure for
700
and i'm just like
[ __ ] my life
i can't buy a 550 figure and a 730
figure at once so i was like the reason
i almost ran out of time was because i
was just sitting there with both figures
next to each other being like
do i go for the win do i go for the
point or do i go for my heart
and always the point
and i looked at the emilia figure and
i'm just like
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna make the
same mistake as subaru i'm gonna go [ __ ]
amelia i'm gonna go for the thing that's
right in front of me and i chose the
fate figure and you know what
i don't regret a damn thing that is
actually the coolest thing i've ever
seen though but you also wouldn't have
got the point anyway if you went for the
image yeah because uh i found one you
see i think you should have looked a
little harder in the hentai section okay
because i found this one and it's uh 935
what is that what is it what can i have
a look at that
it's uh
from uh
which is actually a game i've played
and uh it's it's just like a witch girl
that doesn't from this very 900 yeah but
it's from a very famous uh hentai game
and it's yeah 935
there's the photo
so yeah uh instead i um you went for
your heart i went for my heart and i'm
just and i'm just like i respect that
and i'm just like um so guys so guys um
like if it's like a little too big for
the studio like uh what what are we
doing for the figures
what are we doing if it's like too big
for the studio i think there's like a
place like behind the toilet like like
like yeah we have plenty of room in the
toilet yeah there's plenty room in the
toilet
what if it's too big for the studio like
you know
then it's just then it's just like
useless i don't know if you see how big
the studio is it's it's pretty big
we can get a little pedestal through
behind
you guys you guys aren't fake fans you
guys aren't fake
i think it looks cool
is that enough
while they're still assembling this
absolute
okay it's an absolute unit you want to
get out your
my one my second challenge was get a
figure that could beat goku okay now i
want you to think open-mindedly here
i'm gonna think very close-minded here
bro [ __ ] you
joey what is that
so this is one of the few russian bun
figures that didn't come in a uh in a
box
it just came by itself
joe you've just bought goku
i know i have not i've bought super
saiyan goku black actually you've bought
black goku
i bought super saiyan goku black because
canonically he does kill goku
yeah but so is half of the [ __ ] cast
in dragon ball z so wouldn't you say
that half of the cast in dragon ball z
can beat goku
no he technically looks like he
literally fought goku and killed him
that it means that he beat goku goku is
fighting goku yeah so drac welcome to
dragon ball super buddy
so without have having watched dragon
ball super i know they go to like
multiple universes
and i'm gonna guess that uh this comes
from
one of the multiple universes that's
right but the thing is right super
saiyan black goku goes to the other
universe yourself can beat yourself it's
not this is super saiyan black that's
goku right no it's super saiyan black oh
shoot he's
wait what's the line again don't shoot
he isn't black oh yeah that's it
but he is i don't know if you should get
a character that can beat goku he's
literally a character that kills goku is
that not a character that can beat goku
so would you say that majin buu is a
character that can beat goku yeah
because he literally kills goku yeah but
goku comes back and then beats margaret
have you maybe considered that goku
maybe isn't all that strong
[Music]
the mother joe joe
what are you saying you can't say that
the [ __ ] dies like six times i
don't think a guy who dies six times in
his own show is
considered strong so much and coming
back how does that ask toriyama okay
okay but can he beat goku now in the
latest episode of dragon ball super
right because otherwise otherwise half
of the characters in anime can be like
child goku when he was a kid you know
just because someone can beat him you
are at some point
should have been more specific with the
challenges in that case
what do you think about this connor what
do you think about this i literally
searched up characters that have killed
goku and he was the first one that came
up and i literally saw perfectly the
exact same form as well of when he this
is the hand that took goku's life right
here i think it's [ __ ] but it's alright
you can have the [ __ ] point thank you
all right thank you i don't know
honestly my kindness dude if this wasn't
gonna pass i was about to [ __ ] quit
wait did was that the only thing you can
think of was there like no other there
were possibilities see the problem is
all the other characters that can all
the other characters in dragon ball that
have killed goku canonically just don't
exist honestly
it's all dragon ball super characters
right now i thought you were going to
pick like a jojo character like if if
you would pick like like who like um
like gold experience requiem or
something like that then i'd be like you
know what
you know what there's a dragon ball fan
out there that has an argument against
that rohan rohan could be
no no see like see that all of that is
see all of that is your own opinion
because you guys love jojo more than
dragon ball super this is this is
canonical facts
all right dragon ball
fans what what do you think you have the
final say we're gonna give him the point
now but uh you have the final say in the
comments section if you say no to this
then i think you should quit being a
dragon ball bring bring bring on the
bring back monolith holy crap oh
my god
the structural integrity of this seems
questionable that looks amazing that is
actually one of the coolest things i've
ever seen [ __ ] i regret nothing oh my
god
i hate that it's good
look at that look at that that's like a
statue you'd win at an award
dude that's that's
you know what you know what i'ma say it
[ __ ] amelia
[ __ ] emilia [ __ ] the hentai figure [ __ ]
the hentai figure
every penny where do we put this
i i don't know guys right away well
where do we put this i'm just saying
though it's like perfect diamond for the
little area behind
toilet on guys come on this doesn't
come
the
deserve to go in the toilet
oh my goodness this would be great to
look at while it's pissing this this
looks even better in
like in person than it did in the
pictures it's pretty good
get this out of here get this out of my
sight wait wait wait we'll keep you in
there with that it's literally blocking
my camera guys it's all right it's
blocking
let me look at it for just putting up
it's taking up like a quarter of just a
bit there you go you didn't want to see
me
it's a statue
and the final figure from lashing man
well what was your challenge i'll tell
you what my challenge i'll tell you the
story go on it was to buy a non-anime
figure okay and i'm surprisingly very
difficult because i thought okay well if
i bought something like overwatch you'd
be like oh no
there's overwatch animations it doesn't
count yeah you know there's all this
nonsense and [ __ ] that you guys would be
[ __ ] mean about and then i found the
terminator figure and i thought oh
that'd be great turns out there's a
terminator terminated
yeah coming out or something i don't
[ __ ] know everything i found had an
anime found some star wars figures i was
like oh fantastic there's a star wars
truly
the best figure i've ever purchased that
doesn't have an enemy doesn't that have
an
check this [ __ ] out
what
200
[ __ ] is that fantastic beast yeah that
is fantastic oh my god i didn't even
know they sold this why do they sell
gellard grindelwald who is that that
doesn't sound like a real character it's
um
it's johnny deck
johnny depp
that's meant to be johnny depp oh [ __ ]
sake 200 200 the only thing i could find
and after i purchased it in the video i
found a figure that would have met the
criteria for like one dollar or was it i
covered what it was it was something i
was pissed off i buried it in my mind
why is this [ __ ] [ __ ] this movie
sucked
i haven't even seen fantastic i haven't
even seen it yeah yeah [ __ ] it's me why
is this like [ __ ] oh it looks [ __ ]
oh i guess why does it smell so bad yeah
i i guess you can keep that one for
yourself no no no no
you should
of course you want grindelwald on the
set who wouldn't want grindelwald uh uh
kellet grindelwald
why does he have okiyasu here
what does he look like he's like the
[ __ ]
hello he looks like he's mid
transformation into edward scissors
hands what so can someone explain
fantastic beasts to me it's it's it's a
spin-off of the harry potter series
right i'm pretty sure yeah it's set in
the same universe but it doesn't mention
hogwarts or any of its characters
it's the time before oh sorry well you
know i haven't seen it i enjoyed the
first movie a lot no yeah i was excited
for the second movie did you like gerald
grindelwald or whatever that was [ __ ]
she
and the second movie was [ __ ] it was so
bad and i was really annoyed because i
really liked the first one yeah and i'm
pissed is he only in the second one
uh he appears like a little bit in the
first round but like like so what's the
plot of fantastic beasts oh [ __ ] off
it's complicated is it yeah
i've never known what has got to do with
harry potter this is the main bad guy
it's just in the same universe
that's it yeah yeah it's in the same
universe as it's written by jk yeah okay
okay i could see oh wow his joints move
oh you can make him you can make him
walk and get on his knees
you know connor at least it's not a
funko pop yeah exactly you don't lose a
point two hundred dollars
what's this
[Music]
you spent
like 4200
i think johnny depp is buying that i
kept them in business
what i want to know is yeah who who is
buying fantastic beasts figures out of
here i'm sure there are like harry
potter otaku's out there right yeah
definitely get this out of my mind
yeah
don't say dumbledore but i did my i did
my challenge he is in the he is in the
movies yeah yeah and yeah that was uh
everything i bought in lashing yeah same
so how many did you buy three i bought
three i'm sure you spend gamers three as
well i spent five hundred and seventy
eight dollars in dashimbon wow
500
8 000 no 589
i spent
572 dollars wow we were all really close
holy crap wait no this is a stop oh
never mind
am i bad
looks like i just spoiled myself last
time uh i spent 674
dollars all right the next store is a
stop and uh this is the one that we went
to last time and it was a fan favorite
dare i say because it's quite visually
appealing yeah it's really cool really
interesting store
tons of figures and you really do have
to look yeah so i hope you guys spent a
lot of money or bought a lot of figures
i know i bought quite a lot of things
yeah i think i bought like in terms of
pure number um
i think it's either a stop or army army
i bought the most figures i
actually didn't buy a lot oh really okay
so first of all what were your
challenges okay so my two challenges
were
uh mine was one to buy a female figure
and two to bide a lewd figure which is
great pretty easy so i could get two
figures in one and i guess i'll start
off
shop
my figure first i believe this is it
um so i i actually like this was this
was the first time that i actually tried
to be tactical about what i bought um
for once in your life yeah in lashing
once again you know we had riaz like
last year and this time we actually came
in for the clutch yeah this time we had
the fake figure where you know what it
didn't matter i it didn't matter about
the game i just followed my heart
all right so
this was the lude figure that i bought
um so mudan gets ready to censor this uh
because i'm not sure i can't remember
how lude it is i don't think it's hentai
level loot
uh but it is definitely lewds
um
oh and it is that girl
from
i can't remember she's just gone i think
oh it's from um
no no no it's a
boring girlfriend uh what's oh cycano
psychonauts yeah that's the one uh so
yeah it's that girl from cycling yeah do
you want me to point this towards the
camera uh the reason the reason there's
a lot of panty the reason
there is there's a lot of a lot of panty
and from one angle it's safe
and i mean she's uh she's not putting on
thigh highs but uh she is putting on her
socks right and so the reason i bought
this one was because it was a female
figure
it was
a lewd figure and
it was very very close to 420. i'm not
gonna reveal how much this was okay okay
just because i know youtube bought some
other ones but uh yeah well we'll reveal
those at the end but i will say it is
close to 420. oh okay so that's that's
around 520 for that
yeah what what did go into the mahogany
wood what's going on here i mean kind of
stuff is pretty expensive cyclone itself
is pretty expensive and i'm not sure why
like i feel like it's just i i was
surprised that this one cost this much
right it's just like weirdly popular in
japan for some reason i don't know why
but like i i decided to i have no idea
why yeah i decided to go for it because
i couldn't like looking back i couldn't
find many figures that were close to the
420 mark yeah so i like i saw this one i
was like this one's close-ish so let's
just go for this one and see where it
takes right right all right
joey watch which okay
my ones were uh the first one was get a
fist of the north star figure
which was perfect because this is all
styles like one of my favorite manga
series of all time you were so lucky to
get this one in um a stop because you
would have any other star would have
been [ __ ] if you're like it's maybe
like a stop and maybe mandarakey
and uh
no way we chose this one because we know
we knew it could be completed if like
the right circumstances were exactly but
like because it's such an old series
it's rare to find yeah any figures it's
just rare in general to find anything
fistful of the north star related yeah
yeah but i got one you asked did you
actually hell yeah i did god [ __ ] it not
only that i i got a twofer ladies and
gentlemen i got a two for one two for
one i got two for one i not only got my
boy kenshiro but i also got
da or as well as a combo set look at
that oh my god how much were they
these yeah these were uh if i remember
correctly it wasn't actually that
expensive this one
uh these were i think
148 dollars oh together together
yeah it's actually not bad at all
actually i think no no no no i think
this was actually the cheapest one i
think this was 25 dollars
that's pretty cool yeah for for a two i
mean you know these are like kind of i
mean they weren't in box for one yeah
but it was a two for one so you you
line it up like that that's pretty sick
hell yeah boys the boys are back in town
let's go
i'll just show one off that i go yeah
yeah go for it oh my gosh
pretty cool
looking mm-hmm
jotaro figure oh nice oh okay from like
the 90s ova oh yeah oh
i've never really seen i love the dangly
bits actually yeah i've never seen it in
the 60s
i wanted more on the set and i thought
this is really [ __ ] cool because it
must have been modeled after the old 90s
because like jojo doesn't use a [ __ ]
scarf thing in the
in the new one no i'm so glad i didn't
get any jojo figures because otherwise
i'd be losing points left and right
right now i'm glad you didn't get joseph
but also why does he look more like
lupin
oh a little bit a little bit yeah yeah i
mean i just think it was sick i think it
was um not that much as well remember
correctly the problem with a stop is
that you can't actually see which ones
they were that's right yeah so i have to
remember we don't know how much you want
yeah i have to remember it
i remember this one was quite cheap it
was like 2 000 4000 no more than that
like okay yeah pretty good uh what else
do i've got yeah so after i got uh after
i've completed as many challenges as i
could i basically just you know oh this
also completes one of my challenges but
many of my figures which is get a
character from a shirt and protect oh
easy
i did what any guy would do and just
start collecting waifus um
so very admirable i respect that i got
echidna from uh zero season two
i got her school uniform one which is uh
why why because the kid is great this is
cute
oh dude she's so cute what the [ __ ]
bro come on um of course i got a chisel
figure so i couldn't actually find many
cheese
i couldn't actually find many
cheeseburgers
does this count as a funko pop
i just i just wanted to buy one rent a
girlfriend figure because i couldn't
actually find many and uh i couldn't
find any reason yeah i couldn't find
many of chizuru so i don't know if there
was like if not enough had been made uh
these were pretty cheap they were about
in the ten dollar range yeah i could
tell yeah
um
and i mean you know you know i just uh i
just wanted to pump pump the figure
numbers up with uh some girls that
hadn't been on the uh shelf yet
okay i bought uh two other ones that
weren't a challenge so the first one i
got was
mitsuha from kimono noah ah okay [ __ ] i
didn't see that one yeah and because one
of the challenges is get a figure that
is from an anime movie original yeah so
that's one point for me this was
actually the most expensive this was
258. was that wait was it get the most
anime figures from the movie original
was it no no just one i think oh i
thought we had that challenge
was it the
you should double check i'm pretty sure
get the most and i think there's one
from an anime original movie oh wait it
was get one yeah
those two movie challenges right
uh
oh yeah most figures bought from an
anime original movie what have they done
to you
oh my god
well i figured you know it was going to
be kind of difficult to find figures of
anime original movies because they are
quite rare i mean the fact that this is
258 says that this is pretty rare why is
it so expensive because i've i
personally have never seen a yacht
i've never i didn't even know they made
you mean either
if we do if we're doing anime original
figures i will pick up my other one sure
uh i got a promo figure oh nice
um yeah only one uh this one i got a
pretty decent price this one was i saw
that i thought it was quite expensive i
actually because i saw two one was
pretty expensive and one was i actually
have both the these and hindroids from
uh premiere actually they're really nice
yeah
uh how much is this one oh this one was
uh 59 dollars that's not too bad yeah
which like i feel like anime original
figures are hard to find uh so they're
normally like pretty expensive
all right
what did you get connor
i also got another jojo figure because
this one was sick okay how many jojo
figures did you find
that one is good though that one i
actually saw that one i really like it i
just lost the point and so did you
oh did you get a dia or jonathan no
oh wait no that's jonathan right yeah oh
okay thank god okay i got i got confused
i thought it was just
we got jonathan and dio together like i
just i've never seen this one that's
actually really nice that is really nice
i've never seen this anywhere i love the
like lightning effect on the figures i
love the like glow yeah
the ham one that looks like it's just
everything about this figure is sick
it's 150 bucks but
but again i've never seen this figure
before i thought it was really cool and
i love jojo and everyone knows i love
jojo of course so yeah added it to the
collection and it's a beautiful boy
beautiful beautiful beautiful boy well
that's not gonna open the ninja because
it's like it's a bit more finicky i mean
it's
it's nice i wouldn't say
you clearly know that uh tucky is
supposed to be here yeah yeah yeah it's
supposed to it's like it's supposed to
be you spend 500 total on 500 total on
here now
that that doesn't look worth 250 dollars
i'm not gonna lie the other one i bought
was uh the one that i tried to get as
close to 69 with yeah okay that was one
of the challenges yeah and it is from
one of my favorite games oh [ __ ]
oh
that's nice yeah that is nice i love
okami it's so cute there's a stand for
this as well
in the end well i'll tell you at the end
when we when we try and decide because
it should be the same right for everyone
who tried to buy it
yeah maybe maybe
okay um i guess i have one more um i'll
have one more figure which doesn't live
oh you've got five do you want to go
first yeah that's all my ones except for
my last channel oh yeah yeah uh yeah i
got a sebastian michaelis
because it was like the closest to 69.
oh okay okay i guess we'll reveal that
or reveal that at the end yeah yeah
there's just pouring tea i got a bunch
of other ones too mm-hmm
what this is oh i do it's dio
god he's he he is going through like
every part he's he's actually going to
lose because i was points for getting
the same right
that's the road roller one oh i thought
this was too good not to get and it
would look sick on the shelf yeah i
remember which way it goes down yeah
it's this way
yeah and where does this hand go like
here at the back isn't it
oh yeah it's like that yeah yeah yeah so
that looks pretty cool actually i
thought it would look really cute on the
shelf to have a rose i feel like i feel
like so cute i feel like conor's just
rebuilding his set from home right yeah
these actually i wish i had at home
if you guys don't want to have them on
the set i'll gladly take care of them i
thought well that's just so sick like oh
it's so cool that's pretty simple that's
really nice oh there he goes well it
goes to here maybe he wants to ride it
maybe he wants to ride
i got that i got it how many more things
do you have gone i have one more i
should show some more keep going
i got another diy oh my god
you don't know you don't know if you buy
duplicates you lose points all right uh
yeah i know but only one point right
wait he's got three d he's got three
dios he's got three tiers
it's the same character so there's only
one duplicate right
is that is that how it works i think it
should work in even numbers yeah so it
goes like two four six you know yeah so
if you bought one more tutorial yeah
yeah so if you buy one more dio figures
that's two points you know i i bought
sick figures because they were sick you
know they were sick nasty figures and
this one is like a big chunky boy
connor finds a jojo figure that's a sick
figure that's a sick figure
that looks like it's from the uh 90s
yeah yeah that's right a lot of these
looks like that face is different
because like i i remember this scene
from the 90s yeah that's what i went for
exactly yeah yeah you don't often see
the older ova figures but i feel i feel
like they've got a nicer build quality
in some ways mm-hmm
this is cause it's because like it was
like jojo wasn't mainstream when the 90s
ova came out yeah exactly
no no it's so big i just couldn't help
myself
big boy knocked over another big boy
oh [ __ ] this is [ __ ] damn that's a
that's a chunky boy just as a note none
of these our uh our knives all of these
are ashley's knives
so that's the deal nice i think that's
pretty [ __ ] that's really cool that's
really really really really good i think
it's this one that's a really cool
figure which light would be i don't
[ __ ] know i hate these stands yeah
which one is it do we know just give it
a base yeah yeah
it's his stand
that's a jojo reference
god what's your final figure before i
show my final one all right all right
gentlemen
as joey has just shown
you've heard
of goku black
[Music]
i did you did not get that thing well
let me introduce you to
you did not
you did not get that figure oh you
didn't get that figure let me introduce
you to
black goku
i was hoping one of you would have
bought this i'm not sure i was like
does it matter tell me how much it was
it was
uh
how much was this
oh my god it was a
went wrong
who made this i think i think someone at
the factory [ __ ] up and i clearly
forgot to like paint it
who's trying to sell an unfinished
figure it's like somebody like somebody
in the factory was like all right we've
got the model down perfect uh now we
just gotta apply pain and they're like
uh it's going out
like the detail is really really good
but he's just like he's just sunburned
what
you mean he like ran into the sun then
yeah probably but like he's a charred
that is that actually looks really cool
it does it does is this like a character
in dragon ball fighterz that hasn't been
released yet
it's like the secret fighter is this the
secret fighter that we've been waiting
for the final boss it's like a dark link
right yeah
so i don't know i just saw that and i'm
just like i just need to buy this just
so i can say what the [ __ ] happens you
know that i mean to be fair that's
actually really cool it's really cool
but uh
wait hold on do i lose a point because
we both got goku i guess
great awesome after all that convincing
i tried to do
and i just lose the point
all right so my second challenge at a
stop was to get a figure from an anime
that i ever reached
but you you got goku black right no
this is actually the goku that goku
black kills
the same character they they both lose
this is what happens when you fight goku
that's the point
you turn into black goku
we all lost a point
we literally all no
i i i actually think canonically
yeah check this is is that because
that's just regular goku that's just
painted if it was like a re-skin if i go
like super saiyan goku asking the
viewers they would say goku is the goku
black no no no no no no no no no no no
dragon ball z
dragon ball fans dragon ball z
you know you know that i'm right we
always you know you know i'm right we
all lose a point actually what do you
think
what
we all lose a point actually no no i
guess no thanks what do you mean you
guess that there's no use same character
not the same guy what is his name it's
goku black
no no it's black goku
i bought super saiyan goku black no no
it's goku oh no he has another [ __ ]
name he has another name
oh zamasu zamasu yeah no no it's a
different character it's a different
character
it's literally a different character
thank you thank you thank you
thank you dragon ball super for being
stupid we should ask twitter a poll take
a picture they'll say that it's the same
character no
yeah exactly yeah because you know if
the viewers watch this the viewers
you know you know you know i i
if it was if we were asking dragon ball
fans they would they would they would
agree with their degrees
super saiyan goku black totally
different no it's the same all right my
second challenge at a stop was to get a
figure from an anime that i ever
recently watched so nothing
see
so what did we count as recently again
three months you said three months right
yeah yeah which means that it has to be
either from this season or at least last
season right that's three months but you
can you could have watched an old anime
right well you know i think you forget
there's one very very very popular anime
this season that has actually come out
that i did actually watch but i didn't
watch it this season i watched it quite
a while ago
oh my
god
do you guys know that this doesn't count
that doesn't that doesn't count excuse
me you go on to mal you look up anime of
this season uh i'm pretty sure demon
slayer mugen restaurant okay wait wait
wait actually comes out watch it within
the past three months yeah yeah
what did you do why we watched it no you
haven't have you yeah i have no you
haven't [ __ ] you no you [ __ ] have it
wait for what for what reason have you
re-watched it because i thought it was a
good movie no you have not watched it
you have not look i'm sorry you guys
said look on mal and if it's from this
season or last season then it counts
you must have watched it within the past
three months
what have you what it said what have you
watched it within the past three what
have you watched in the past three
months
[ __ ] nothing obviously that's why i
picked this
it's from this season you guys said it
needed to be from at least
three months
three months it came out within the past
three months you have to have watched it
in the last out within the past three
months i'm sorry i saw it earlier yeah
but it came out in the last three months
recently i don't care it came out
no we we literally we literally picked
that challenge beforehand because we
knew it would [ __ ] you over if you got
it and you could you somehow got it
i'm i'm saying if i get the most
expensive figure challenge joey then you
got to take the l on this one i'm sorry
man
you clearly took the l in the most
expensive one
i l you literally said that came out
within the last three months this came
out within the last three months no we
said watching what we probably
never said what is the matter what is
the exact wording of the challenge
figure from an anime that you've
recently watched
recently
recently were you [ __ ] making up this
mouth [ __ ] yeah i might as well not have
eyes either because i clearly didn't
watch anything in the past three months
you guys knew that
obviously so i obviously made the
[ __ ] rules well well
it's not our fault
it's not my fault anime has been mid as
[ __ ] this year right
i know what an anime you watched
recently what made an abyss you
re-watched it no the movie uh yeah you
re-watched maiden abyss right that
didn't come out in the last three months
no no yeah it literally doesn't say come
out in the past three months yeah it
said recently right within the past that
is not recent yeah but you re-watched it
have you watched okay so hold on what
was this supposed to be because you guys
said it watched in the last three months
but you guys brought on the [ __ ]
rule of it needed to be it needed to
have come out in the last three months
yeah you said no no it needed you needed
to have watched it in the last no no no
i have video proof you said it needed to
have come out in the last three months
when you provide that
when you when you provide video proof
it's live right now is this episode
i don't see the video proof right now so
i guess we'll have to uh wait for the
day but this came out in the last three
months
all right all right ashley how how many
contentious points do we have now we
have the joe most
we we have the goku black i think most
of the points are content all right i i
think we might need to uh wait off uh
well and we might need to wait off uh to
let the audience decide some of these
points and then we can do like the
forfeit well later then do you know our
audience they're gonna do everything
they can to [ __ ] us over well that's
it's it's
they're not gonna give us the point it
might as well be zero points look look
audience we're gonna make a poll on
reddit and uh we're gonna we're gonna
that's the worst idea we're gonna ask
you this is literally the worst
i've ever heard
that's the last place i go to doorpool
you don't even have to take it out of
the box man we know what he looks like
yeah you don't want to see it no i'm
good man i know what he looks like
that's good let's go josh let's go about
the knife let's go joe just whip out the
neck or importantly though how much did
you guys spend at a stop i spent because
you won't actually believe this because
i
this was completely coincidental i
literally spent 500 exact really yeah
look i spent 500 holy [ __ ] i spent
572
dollars
okay and how much did you spend connor
well i'm just getting my
gorgeous
that's it
wait he doesn't have a stand no he like
goes on the side of a table oh
it's gonna look good on the desk oh yeah
i actually see the box it says noodle
stopper figure what does that mean that
means you put it on
okay um so i spent a total of
six hundred and twenty dollars oh damn
well before we move on from a stop
though i wanna hear the story about what
the [ __ ] you went through in a stop oh
i lie i forgot a figure oh never mind
and it's my coolest and most expensive
oh okay
uh do you want to carry on with that
thing though or no no no no no no go
show you show your show
close your eyes boys
i'm gonna i want to unbox it fully
before i show you
i think i know what it is yeah it's the
[ __ ] most coolest figure yeah it's
the one that we all saw last year as
well was it there last year
is it from that one series i haven't
seen yet no no no no no no no no no no
no
perhaps a certain no
don't
i i have no idea what the [ __ ] you're
talking about i know
you're gonna be i i saw him pick this
out so yeah but you did yeah i saw you
well you just have spoilers joey yes i'm
just gonna i'm just gonna open my eyes
because i don't know what it is
it looks so dumb outside of the box
opening my eyes at all
this is one of the dumbest and yet
coolest figures i've ever seen it's the
most epic figure yeah [ __ ] time if i
can get it open sorry
god really uh
really uh dragging this out corner drag
my nuts
all right
all right can i go on in three
two
[Laughter]
the [ __ ] one amazing
where did you find you see this i didn't
see it it was there last year as well it
was 300 yeah
i'd say worth it honestly well this is
so sweet
in which box would that fit in how did
they display that it was it's literally
like
[Laughter]
okay that's the box it comes in
i love i love this scene in hunter
hunter and i just when i saw it and i
knew i had the spare budget i couldn't
yeah i couldn't say no the only reason
why i didn't buy this last year is
because it was over our budget yeah yeah
it's so sick yeah i actually wish i
brought it like fences
i actually wish i bought more in a stop
because there were like more cool
figures that i wanted to buy but like i
didn't know how much i would be spending
in like the next ones yeah yeah um but
looking back um i wish i there were so
many figures that i wish i had bought
there were like some black lagoon
figures and some gaps
yeah the gowns figure i really wish i
had bought yeah yeah the gangster was
cool actually so hot yeah but i mean i'm
but i mean like a stop's a cool store um
so it's lashing band there were so many
cool figures in lashes they're in the
same building as well yeah exactly
careful this was 160 dollars
it's pretty sturdy
is that the most expensive figure oh no
this is the most this is the 300 yeah
this is
close to the 40s it's like the flimsiest
plastic thing ever but yeah
i imagine it's i imagine it's just that
much because of how pretty rare it is
yeah i do i mean i've never seen that
before i've never seen that i don't know
where you even buy it or where you get
it from i i it must have been available
quite a while probably a collective
collector's item it's it's just the
coolest thing i've ever seen it's so
ridiculous like isn't this amazing i
love it i love it so much
yeah this this has a different center of
gravity
honestly it does
it's very top-heavy
a little bit make sure you kind of feel
like how dumb it would look in real life
if you sure gone when he was going super
saiyan all top
but yeah that was my uh this is my hall
at h you bought a lot of days yeah i
mean you mostly all of it was this oh
yeah mostly it was jojo figures yeah
mostly it's three dios and a gone yeah
so four jojo figures uh black baller
black butler and uh
it's pretty good oh can it be black goku
all of these can beat goku i think
that's still my favorite
[Laughter]
that's your favorite when we have this
joey how dare you proud
the thing is i saw this one last year i
just can't believe this one's real
and it like unironically looks epic as
well
i can't get
[Laughter]
so we found a meme recently which is
just like um like ultrasound
goku with the caption could you repeat
that and it's like you can see his dick
just half chopped off it's it's it's
like the edge of his [ __ ]
on the screen is the funniest thing i've
ever seen in my life all right was uh
that was that was a stop moving on i
need the toilet so before we move on to
amiami though um joey what was this
thing about this guy buying kirito
figures that i've heard about
oh yeah yeah yeah so when i was lining
up at a stop there was a dude in front
of me it's in my video as well but there
was a dude in front of me in like a
full-on business so it was like a proper
japanese salary man and uh i overheard
and i thought i thought i doubted myself
for a second i overheard the words
kirito
and 600 thousand yen
i thought
which is six thousand dollars six
thousand dollars
and i was like
excuse me
that that can't be right did you get a
glimpse i leaned in closer no i think he
ordered it in bulk at asoc because i
think there was just too many and then i
found out as i was you know he left and
as i was checking out and you know i
talked to the dude i was like so uh the
guy the guy before me
what what did he buy if you don't mind
me asking and he said oh he bought six
thousand dollars worth of kirito figures
they do exist and i was like oh my god
they actually exist
these types of waves exist so he
literally went into the store and said
i'll take your entire team [ __ ] your
entire story
kirito figures who's buying six thousand
dollars worth of kirito for that dude he
was probably like in his maybe mid 30s
right
just buying like i think he bought like
13 or 14 kirito figures like so many
that he didn't even like bother bringing
them up he i think he just gave them the
paper and said just send it to me
oh my dropped his money and they just
left is this like an investment is is is
he like is this
like a kirito
that's the only explanation i have for
this guy it was insane a big fan you
know i guess so all right boys what
challenges did you have at amiami so for
army army we have three challenges
because uh we yeah we just want to make
it a little spicy yeah yeah we thought
that we could spend a lot of money there
yeah and and we did we uh this was
probably going to be the longest segment
yet because we bought a lot of figures
so my one were fairly varied my one was
get a figure that's american uh buy a
wall scroll and buy an incestuous series
and shout i love incest while holding it
uh now for the incestuous one i'm gonna
have to finish that here because i
didn't have enough time to actually grab
it and shout it because literally the
moment i picked it up sounds really
convenient to me but literally the
moment i picked it up the staff came
over and just took it out he's like this
one okay took it out of my hands i was
like
i can't even tell him i like incest yeah
that's how damn i was like wait no i
have to say i like you that's just like
stage hazards you know it's not it's not
it's no one's fault but you should have
done it i'll be happy to take half a
point for this honestly because
i'd be lucky to get half a point on this
joke i'd like i'd like to at least get
half one because i did buy i did finish
half the challenge i did actually buy an
incestuous figure i just literally
didn't have the time to get you know say
the thing so if if we're nice to you
you're saying you'll be nice to us at
some point i have to be nice to you guys
what do you mean
all right i got us back
shouted out on the podcast so i can
judge what the [ __ ] ladies and gentlemen
that i shout out era manga sensei just
forgot
everybody round of applause
hold on joey well done i'm proud of you
i'm proud of you joey we go to prison
this is the only one i was like there
has to be an oriental figure yeah please
let there be an armor this is the first
time i ever in my life prayed for an
orimo figure yeah couldn't find it so i
was like [ __ ] what else what else is
incest what else is incest i know i'll
ask the incest man right here so i ran
up to ghant i said bro
if you scratch my back i'll scratch
yours
what's an incest shot
and i and i just gave him some uh
philosophical [ __ ] that i made up on
the spot yeah even though i've i saw
about 10 erimanga sensei figures along
the way why is there so many
i don't know i don't know i don't know
it's popular enough i guess but uh it's
okay okay
i guess replace this lemon style yeah
yeah but yeah there you go i found
myself a sagiri figure uh it's actually
not too bad to be honest with you i'm
not exactly a fan of uh erimanga sensei
but this is actually pretty solid i
think you'd have the fbi knocking if you
said you were well i mean gone should be
used to that by now
uh this one was uh 211 dollars
211 dollars for an air market
yeah this i mean i don't know where i
didn't have like your eagle like incest
eagle vision so uh this is the only one
i could find
i'm okay not seeing the figure you know
i'm sure there's like a child's play mat
there what the [ __ ] is that yeah i'll
bring it out but i'll bring it out don't
worry
i think it's supposed to symbolize
sagiri's like bed right what happens in
this anime why is it children's style uh
because she is a hentai artist
she's uh yeah yeah the her she's like
she's the error manga she's the aramonga
yeah and the and and the brother i
believe is an era manga author right
he's like yes
bro she's practically got like the
[ __ ] cars bed bro what is that she's
not she's not a hen basically this
figure um this series is like the series
from hell you know this is this is the
series it truly is oh no what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that
all right and what the [ __ ] and the
grand river why is it like a child's
play mat
i mean how old is saggier again in the
show i have no idea uh you do not want
to know yeah probably not probably
probably not legal
probably we're not gonna be allowed to
say that yeah probably not allowed to
say it there's some kind of like
liability on alpha
oh
there you go there's
i think this goes where does this go
basically the series like should burn in
hell uh
and that's why i memed it up so much
yeah what didn't you i remember a
certain gig making a video called i love
this dumpster truck or something like
that i think it's literally called error
market sensei is a master it's a
masterpiece
there you go there's the masterpiece
right there
i love incest
hey i completed the challenge yeah you
proud of me i'm probably proud of you
you've completed uh you've completed
your character arc now
i did it guys are you proud of me mom
[Laughter]
i'll keep this here because i still have
to set it up but what were your guys's
challenge i mean i guess i'll take out
my first challenge mm-hmm
well why don't we towels the challenges
first guys we have some reason to
understand you know the first challenge
yeah so obviously you guys know my first
challenge
because we told you to buy it because
you guys told me to buy it and uh
i'm i'm gonna be honest with you
i uh i'm not exactly unhappy with it
honestly because because you guys were
gonna get what were you guys gonna make
me buy again ram ram
okay you you were gonna make me buy ram
or mama
not mamako if there was one other
[ __ ] [ __ ]
whoa
um the uh the the shore girl with big
bajungas
yeah so this is uh
so the alternate
title for this is the milfisa guy yeah
do you like your mum with her two hit
multi-target attacks english title oh
that is one big figure that's a thick
mama right god damn
goddamn
thank you those those are some high
heels look at that
jesus how do i put this in
okay there we go honestly honestly i'm
happy with this figure so i got this
premise and it's a goal and she's going
huge but i would like to take it huh i
would like to have one what what do you
think connor that's very good as the
milf map much better than whatever the
[ __ ] this is although i haven't even
this isn't even a masterpiece yeah so so
joey so joey this one's still got a
paper on it take it off the queen
the queen
okay so joey yeah um when you were
asking for incest anime yeah you could
have also got this one
oh yeah because yeah because she does
does she does do weird stuff with her
songs yeah she does what yeah she just
wants yeah yeah so she gets in like a
slime bar with them son the premise of
this show the premise of this show is a
son gets isikai's with his mom and this
this ain't erimanga sensei oh they're
not related by blood no they're fully
related by blood and she came out of her
yeah like he came out he he got birthed
from her vagina um he came out of the
womb and everything uh she raised him
and uh she uh she turned him into a
degenerate apparently
and there are some very very like i'll
drink to that there are some
very uh
sexy scenes on that what happens we're
talking about episode two right i'm
talking about episode
um so in episode two i think let's just
say that's the episode that made me drop
the show yeah in episode two i believe
they fight a slime monster right and
this slime monster
uh has acid or slime which corrodes
everything except the body the body yeah
so it basically melts the it melts the
clothes off yeah
yeah yeah and uh guess guess who gets
that slime all over her body
and uh guess who
is on her body when the slime
goes on her body yes it is her son um
yep and the and the sun is this slime
where does that go and uh and
i don't actually remember the scene i
don't i believe it just go gets rid of
her clothes yeah something like that he
has like anti-slime clothes
yeah
but yeah that was the one like episode
that made me drop this show otherwise uh
amazing artwork yeah
one of my favorite artists oh she has
amazing artwork yeah oh very nice
they probably got like the uh the
fishnets for that didn't yeah [ __ ]
yeah i i love i have i haven't as [ __ ]
yeah yeah i think i i'm too tall
i have a couple of bunny goal figures
damn boy
all right well that's a figure yeah i
thought you would like this one i do
yeah and you've talked about that slime
it's a bit no no you're not really
interested you're talking about the
slime i'm more excited clearly her heart
is already taken by someone
so connor was the first figure that you
bought then well i spent a lot of money
here so
perfect
bloody hell that's a long receipt you
bet it is so i had one challenge which
was to buy something from a movie that
joey buy something from an anime that
joey has watched in 2021 yeah okay
which is a little easier than what you
should buy one you saw recently yeah
yeah it's not like i've seen zero this
year unbelievably i know
luckily this wasn't too difficult as
last minute before we had to leave the
store i remembered that joey in length
had spoken about watching the evangelion
movie yeah so i bought i just bought
neva oh nice oh nice i know what you're
gonna say you're gonna be like oh it's
not the the right type from the right
because i know it has the movie on it
but it isn't it isn't though no it isn't
it isn't
that's not that's not even close you had
so many ava options
actually that's you know what it is
that's not even like canon evangelion
what's even going this is evangelion in
train form
it's even going what the [ __ ] actually
yeah yeah it's not even an eva it's an
ava collab with shinkaniong oh it's ava
which [ __ ] did you buy
you had so many choices of ava
have you bought a [ __ ] ava shinkansen
what have you done
what have you done connor
if it's a jojo collab with a t-shirt
it's still jojo you know what i mean
it's still evangelion what are you
obviously about to ask connor i should
get the point yeah that's uh that's
proper there you go you also bought an
evangelion gun yeah so you both lose a
point no no yes oh okay we don't we do
yeah yeah
i got him i got a point and then lost it
yeah no you didn't even get a point you
lost it no i get it it's just even now
you don't even that is not you look if
we're not going to count my recent anime
well we're not counting
bro
that's the average that's a [ __ ]
shinx though this is a that's
you literally could have picked so many
evangelion figures you picked the one
that's a [ __ ] train either
none of uh either i get no point yeah
i'm happy i'm content with making god
lose a point
i will give you the point if you can if
you can say that i get the point for the
[ __ ] uh humans on the eyeball no no
no because it's the exact same thing he
gave you the half a point for the year
no because the exact same vein no it's
not yes it is
i'm sorry i don't remember watching shin
cutty on in 2021 it wasn't about
watching shin kalyan it's about getting
old it is
figure series it literally says it on
the [ __ ] box
i need to know connor why did you choose
that figure there was so many ava
figures there because all of them look
so boring what about the bna one that
you said you were gonna buy
yeah i found out that because we
literally did a video this year on the
netflix yeah then i went to my calendar
and we actually filmed that in like
december oh really so god damn so gant
loses one point and i get nothing cause
i lost the point i gained oh we both no
no you both lose the point both lose the
point yeah and then i get the point for
now you don't get the point i only lose
the point if i get the point because
you'd have to admit that it's an eva for
me to lose the point to begin
with so what i'm saying is right if you
agree that means it's either you lose no
points or you lose two points no it's
either i lose no points or god gets a
point
no i don't get any points he doesn't get
any points i just don't lose a point
yeah so then i get a point you know what
you're losing the point if you if you
admit that you lose a point you're
admitting this is an evangelion i'm
going crazy
this isn't this isn't okay okay you know
what you know what i'd rather i'd rather
not admit that that's the evangelion
then admit that we got the same figure
yeah so
i'll tell you what yeah so doesn't lose
any points and you don't lose any points
how's that we're we're exactly where we
[ __ ] start so so both of you have
zero
this isn't even gallium it literally
says it on the box i did not watch
evangelion with a [ __ ] shinkansen
reboot i did i don't know what you were
watching joey i watched the english dub
where they had this in it
look look look they're they're we
literally no way
do you remember that scene in 4.0 when
they bust out the evangelion concept
look we literally in ava 3.0 plus one
got introduced to evangelion infinity
but even in the infinite possibilities i
don't think that was one of them this is
one of the infinite possibilities okay
i don't think even infinity can uh take
account of whatever the [ __ ] that is of
course i don't think so
is that why you're acting so smug joey
no i'm acting so smug because i know
that's not evangelion that clearly says
on the side of the back i can read it's
evangelion what the [ __ ] is this that's
the at field
ah from evangelion right you know what
bring bringing bringing the attention
away from this clown for a moment this
is actually oh my god holy [ __ ]
why are you buying figures they don't
fit in the [ __ ] shelf that's so good
none of these figures fit in the shelf
god i went with my heart okay one of
them i quitted with my heart this just
looks like a cool [ __ ] figure look at
this where are we going to put this guy
i'm back at the toilet all right
there's just gonna be a there's just
gonna be a toilet shrine with all the
cool figures
i'm trying to be the [ __ ] and
actually think about our set for a
moment
yeah see this one fits perfectly on the
set that's not going on the side yeah
look out look how tight it is
it fits perfectly on this get
demonetized every [ __ ] episode what
do you mean she's wearing clothes yeah
in the meantime let me show you oh wait
oh you got apex
what my name is this one's for me this
one's something that's for you i don't
give a [ __ ] about you guys why'd you buy
an apex legend one this is my main is
that to do with a challenge no he just
wanted it i just want a pathfinder he's
my main okay if that's the case
close your eyes boys
i gotta i got the perfect one if we're
talking meme games okay uh i got the the
perfect one right here right and uh open
your eyes
i saw somebody
why did you buy this i got the i got the
full box set
[ __ ] sake
i couldn't not buy this this is
absolutely amazing oh no you didn't gone
wait did you buy the same thing
[Music]
oh
no
all right
joey what did you buy exactly
i bought
wait
uh oh
oh oh i bought the buildable action
figure
uh among us five to collect why they're
five
all right so uh one of my one of my
challenges was of course to get a
plushie yeah and uh i had a plenty of
options to find a lot of character
plushies
um sorry and then like
for some reason
and then uh hidden right in the corner
joey and then right in the corner
what's up
i'm august
yeah you both lose a point yay what the
[ __ ]
what the you know what worth it for the
among us you know you know although you
know though i didn't want to stop there
because uh the plushie where you got
moromagus the plushie needed a friend
okay the plushie
okay look
look i i know the challenge was just to
buy one character plushie yeah but i
felt like you know you can't play among
us with just one just one person okay
okay
the character needs a friend okay
i got steve as well
hell yeah let's
of minecraft go
boy steve
we're selling our own smash bros right
here yeah right
well among us in smash when
that's practical
yeah i couldn't not get this yeah this
was too perfect what is this so these
are like buildable i guess like like
lucky boxes for a mogus character yeah
it's among us it's a mongoose gacha
can we get the boxes off the table
luckily none of these are the red the
red amongst yeah
so does it count is it the same
character i don't know does it count
because none of them are red well let's
open them up and find out who is uh no
yeah
from the same series none of these are
red though
oh yeah he's from the same series yeah
but you've bought how many series from
jojo yeah yeah only one set of
duplicates
yeah but that that was only one set
right because it was yes so so you so
if i'm counting this is one yeah yeah so
you guys you got the humongous guy
that's literally a character no no i got
i got the red among them because they're
not they're not different they're all
the
same
there's the white
one there's the purple the green the
black the white and the red glow in the
dark they're all the same characters
look look look they're just different
costumes it's the same color when you're
voting for someone to get off right well
dude it's the same it's a different
costume it's the same character yeah
we've already established we both lose a
point and i get a point because it's ava
no no no no no we've established that we
both don't lose a point
no
no
he has not bought a red among us
character you can see there you can see
on the [ __ ] box they are the same
characters when you vote someone after
you go the among us character no you say
reddit sas connor you don't go
among us
you got reddit
[ __ ] purple
what's their name it's red well it's a
crew mate it's red he's a crew it's a
red crewmate it's a red crew mate yeah
and that's a crew mate it's a red
crewmate they're both the same because
this is the green logic joey's probably
bought like 15 duplicates here no
because i'm counting this as one because
it came in one box
well if you open them all up how many
characters are there
five yeah so you have five duplicates no
because this is one all right well you
can either take the five minus points or
you can take the one minus points here
that it
i am going to argue this till the day i
die if there was a red among us
character i will happily take the l yeah
i agree if there was a red among his
character i'd be like joey yeah we got
the same
character because i literally
i literally tried like i literally like
predicted maybe one of these character
maybe one of these guys will buy an
among us character right so i was like
so i was like which i actually had to
pick one that i thought the guys
wouldn't actually buy so i picked red
yeah and luckily there's no real well it
sucks that you both got the crewmates so
it doesn't matter anyway you both lost
the point in the end that's a red
crewmate and there isn't a point off of
them both
audience what do you think audience what
most definitely going to say
what is this under the contention
ashley isn't this the stupidest [ __ ]
your honor your honor i object
you object you can't you will look like
clowns
you both lose one point oh my god
there's no doubt about it all right i
actually bought a b stars figure because
i wanted to take it away from connor
just in case i bought as well hell yeah
no no not not now like in my
in my personal life
don't tell me that you're like oh that's
the one i bought joe
i i pre-ordered this before it came out
oh okay yeah yeah it's really yeah
because i was looking around and i'm
just like well i've got all my points
let's try it let's try to [ __ ] over um
so you know it didn't matter in the end
anyway yeah it didn't matter hell yeah
that's it's such a nice figure as well
it is
did you even watch peace stars this year
though uh yeah season two i did okay
yeah so yes that did you take one point
off of them actually uh it's under
contention
we're having points on the contention
this year what the [ __ ] take it off for
them no no it's under contention this is
not under under what what the court of
the clowns what the [ __ ] you know the
court of the law
the court among us the court of among us
the court of the sus
i'm sorry i'm sorry but if we're going
far by among us laws then the majority
wins right it's by major majority votes
so therefore therefore you would have
you would have been voted out if you're
both in agreement you can't just both
keep making up rules and then say we
have the majority
we're not making overalls that's
literally what you just did we did an
emergency meeting we voted and we voted
that your opinion was voted off because
you're in the same game the same figure
and the same characters so they voted
the same character are you colorblind
the same character
there is not none of these look like
this character they literally look the
exact same none of these they're all the
crew members they're literally the same
character i can't believe this is
they're the same character how can like
six of them go around at the same time
they're all wearing different costumes
gone
because why because they're all the same
characters because they're different
characters johanna no they're wearing
what do you think
are you telling me they're all clones or
yes they are lit that is literally the
point of the thing is that you can
change color because there is no
distinction between them because they
are the same character
what if what if this guy's name is gary
and this guy's name is greg it's not
well how do we know have you have you
looked into amongst them at all yes they
don't have any names they're all the
same character
so every fact so all among us characters
are just clones of each other yes
i like to hear your opinions among us
fans uh anyone who's uh
knows anything about among us law i
think can back us up that uh these are
all different characters
all right bring out the uh what else is
in my box
what else have i got i'm i'm just gonna
keep bringing that [ __ ] out so the other
challenge i had was to buy a wall scroll
so uh i just bought a show what's wrong
do you even need to see it no no okay no
one cares it's like no one cares
yeah i mean like my challenges were to i
mean one of them was this and one of
them was that so that's both of my
challenges because the next challenge
was to uh squat anytime i saw every zero
figure and i really regret not going to
the gym because my [ __ ] god that
burnt the next day i'm not even joking
right because now that i've moved into a
house with stairs
just going up to my bedroom hurts
i'm just like i just after that i just
bought figures that i liked
oh i wanted to get that got his county
figure i wanted to get that so bad um
just because i i've never seen a fully
cooling fully represent
boys that's the blue candy too yeah yeah
i have a red candy at home actually
hell yeah so i mean
i'm glad that they're still making fully
cooling figures are they still is this
new because i didn't know this results
right isn't everything at army army like
relatively new i think this is from the
second hand
um is it from the second hand section
yeah it's from the second hand right um
yes literally says 1990.
no no that's when it came out oh okay
okay
yeah so uh that's that nice uh ashley
can you get me the the lamp
yeah this is something that i was gonna
buy yeah so i kind of saw me reaching
out for this and i thought it was too
cool not to get yeah i wanted to get
this for myself for the longest time but
i got a majora's mark it's not a figure
but i thought it looked cool in the
studio it's a majora's mask
light up statue yeah sydney actually
went back to amiami and bought this oh
really like two days after it's pretty
sick it is really good that looks that
would look amazing
it off to them they can get it oh yeah
good idea
well um
a bunch of [ __ ] from anime only movies
just to win this this prize
oh a ton of food all the ghibli stuff
like 5 000 of them just so i make sure
that i get that done
wow
it's all jubilee too yeah i don't know
why i didn't think of jubilee yeah i
don't know why i just wanted to either
uh one two like when i when i i remember
the challenge of anime only movies and i
was like oh man how many hosoda figures
are there no because i was just like how
many shinkai figures i was like pro
that's a that's an anime only akira
jerry's gonna i figured it would be
whoever got the most because it was the
most anime figures yeah sorry i thought
i got mistake i thought it was the most
expensive no no no so i bought six from
ghibli all right
you've got that point
you've got that point but do you have a
majora's mask lamp i don't think so but
i have um
this is sick though like you can
actually put food in it and it will like
chomp it and spit it out
what do you need that for i don't know i
just thought it was it was cool to have
no face figure that can chomp and spit
[ __ ] fair enough no yeah i guess uh
fire from house that's cute right
calcifer i think uh
yeah you can see you can hear you can
hear nabi um cheering because is it okay
this is the only thing that gets now be
excited it's oxton because she's okay
it's it's okay altar the [ __ ] is this
what is this it's okay someone's the
best looking fate some sometimes you
roll for a character and uh you are
unfortunately oh it's from fate yeah
yeah yeah later
it talks to alter those the best
character from honestly this this is
like
in terms of like her ranking in terms of
gameplay it's like it's it's not the
best but in terms of [ __ ] design holy
[ __ ] this is one of my favorite designs
i agree and if you bought this you would
have got a point joey because i don't
own her i tried tried rolling for her
did not get her um well
we'll we'll find out about that later
that was in monroe i was in monday yeah
and that's and that's why you know if
you can't if sometimes you roll for a
gacha and you don't get it so sometimes
you go out your way and you own them
physically and that's uh that's what i
did okay okay so my biggest challenge at
army army was to get a figure of a
character that is american
okay now i had to double check here
right
it didn't say anime character it just
said character right because admittedly
there isn't a whole lot of american
anime characters there's a few there's a
few like that guy from yugioh yeah
there's a few but definitely not
famous enough to make a figure out of
yeah right but luckily i i checked with
the staff and i said okay does it
necessarily have to be anime it doesn't
say it needs to be anime so as long as
it's an american and you guys have no
problems with it being an american then
i thought it was okay right so
i got
probably one of the most american people
ever
lebron james
why is there a lebron james
what american you can't argue it's a
figure
i'll i'll give you that i'll give you
that i'll give you that too
representative
we have we have a lebron james speaker
in the studio
applause ladies and gentlemen why the
[ __ ] is there a lebron if
lebron james can appear in space jam he
can appear in trash taste okay he's
technically an anime character he was in
space too
well i thought cause why is it like
movable
you can make him dunk you can make him
do the finger thing as well it's great i
love this
okay cool actually yeah that's pretty
cool i'm gonna take him out actually
yeah um do you have any more figures
connor uh yeah a few four four more four
more um
i i think i only have one more right i
think i only have one more i don't have
a few more but do you want to take some
more out
really
thanks [ __ ]
yes
[ __ ] you know what you know what guys
i was this close to buying one as well i
was this close oh
no
at least the reason is what your price
was because i was like at least let me
be mine cheaper and it was cheaper so
[ __ ] you you overpaid by 20 bucks that's
all right i'm going to take one of these
home
all right two points off i guess because
we're idiots two points two points you
want to see it
i'm good man i'm good
guys guys we can have one in our both
shows we'll have one in each corner so
one of my challenges to buy a male
character and this was it why that one
you could have gone for any other male
character there's a reason why joey okay
because
i also bought something else to go along
with it okay
oh you bought the motorbike oh you
bought the motorbike i'm so glad you
bought that i don't know because i saw
it and i was like
i don't know because it's not going to
give me any points or anything but oh
there's alter okay
look at that octa ultra dude
damn
goddamn oh it is easily the best looking
fake character i'm i'm sad now though i
don't own her this this is this is
making me so sad i now know that you
don't own her
so this is the bike and yeah it's a big
box yeah i bought this because i well i
was going to buy this because it was 600
and i thought at the time i'm i'm i'm
like i was very confident the time that
it was the most expensive figure i don't
know if you guys bought another one yeah
i still you know from all the stores so
far i think it is i think so far yeah so
the reason why i bought the other figure
was to try and secure the challenge of
spending the most on one series yeah how
much how much was this bike
600 600
oh my god it's like a whole mic it's
like a full-on operation oh my god look
at that this is not a podcast episode
anymore this is just an unboxing yeah
i like how we've just made a glorified
unboxing episode and uh audio aliens are
gonna be so confused yeah if you're
watching if you're if you've come this
far oh
lord
so cool
yo i can only get so erect dog
that's amazing oh it moves holy [ __ ]
that is so cool
holy [ __ ] i hope you can [ __ ] put it
on the set
yeah that's like canada
i hope i hope you can put canada on that
god damn that looks good that is so cool
again that's not that that supersedes a
figure i think that's yeah that's just a
statue
oh dude i really hope you can get him to
sit on it so the main so the main reason
i wanted to get it was because i was
near certain that yeah it did indeed
yeah oh
i mean that's impressive but look at my
boiler
clean
look at that physique that perfect
physique oh look at that look at that
that's so cool so i wonder why it
doesn't really stand up very well i
think in even in the the movie it kind
of leans when it stands yeah but like
it's like that i think i think it needs
to stand on the side right the boys are
low right yeah the set though i thought
that would look sick behind us yeah
having you know a one to sixth scale of
the bike i just thought you can't say no
to that yeah that that's sick you know
what that legitimately looks amazing
yeah uh worth wasting two points for um
so yeah i agree you know what i ain't
even mad i lost two points because we
got that yeah we got that in the [ __ ]
seven yeah right right right isn't this
[ __ ] sick right all right everybody
move way for lebron james
he's like hi
it's me lebron
i got hold on i got i got a musho
kutensei figure because of course i did
um i didn't know if they started making
them already but apparently they did oh
nice i would have preferred
um roxy uh grey rat
yes her name is grey rats error screams
that's like some like iron mouse
copyright situation
honestly
look at the design
[Laughter]
so yeah this is um the lost member of v
shojo apparently uh
yeah i mean i mean i think uh i think
michoacan say is far and beyond the best
issac i've ever seen um so i just i just
wanted to i just wanted some
representation yeah some representatives
has it actually yeah yeah isn't it so
good i finished season one the other day
oh bro yeah have we not talked about
this it's [ __ ] awesome dude i love it
it's such a good [ __ ] show sorry boys
i was pretty distracted that it [ __ ]
moves
that's so cool yeah that's the noise it
makes
he needs the [ __ ] gun with that yeah
he does yeah yeah there's a gun he's the
big fuck-off gun we don't need the gun
right now it's fine yeah can't believe
we bought the exact same figure we both
lost two points i i'm not you know what
the the bike
i'm not even mad i'm not even mad
because you got the bike
i committed i committed jerry it's all
right i'm i'm taking the bro they got
the tinder pout down look at that look
at that it's it's it's the small details
man it's the small detail it's all about
the simple things
all right show off your figure gone huh
show it off to us
stop taking nine years to unbox it i'm
sorry conor i'm sorry rip it open rip
and tear
i thought you didn't do that with your
figures yo he's got google he's got
google maps on the [ __ ] bike yo let's
go google maps bro what the [ __ ] yo they
were thinking ahead
dude the detail is like insane yeah i
know
it is like model car
level off yeah yeah but the light turns
as well oh that's so cool does it like
does the light turn on i don't know i
don't think so nice that's not bad yeah
very clean oh [ __ ] we have to actually
build it okay we probably can't do it
now
yeah yeah it's customizable so it comes
i'll just show the camera yeah yeah show
the camera which comes with a bunch of
uh different customizations yeah yeah
cool we can build that on stream yeah
yeah yeah okay do you want to take this
away i'll just leave this on here for
now all right i still have one more
figure by the way okay and it's the
biggest one i have
is it that one there's that one right
there do you want to we don't have to
unbox it now i have to unbox it just
just put the box on the thing
joe i didn't know you were a hatsune
miku fan what can i say i like anime
we've gotten to the point where the
figures we've bought we buy are so big
that it's actually blocking us yeah uh
so i'm not gonna unbox this but this is
the memorial dress uh hatsune miku
um
yeah that one is also the one that is
closest to 420 for me okay we'll we'll
so we'll uh well funny enough the
one of the things i have left is the
closest to 420 for me oh nice oh okay
all right
i don't know what the [ __ ] this is pull
it out it happened to be so close to 420
what the [ __ ] is that
[Applause]
thank god i do not know what this is uh
this is
megazone23
i don't know what that is i'm guessing
it's like a super obscure yeah it's
probably a super old makeup show
where will i get it destroyed for
calling this a transformer because it
kind of looks like a transformer
so i'm guessing this is some very og
isn't garland like a different character
from a different show yeah it's final
fantasy right i'm guessing it's rare or
something because it's 420 i think it's
like i think i think just looking at the
font of the show name it looks like an
old show uh in like the mech section of
me oh
like that's what it looks like so i
guess yeah i don't want to be here all
day opening for you guys yeah yeah yeah
yeah so yeah we'll just take that off
stream good stuff that's my closest i
have one more uh how many do you have
left i'm done would you want to go first
i just went
okay um so uh oh you go first because
this one's a hentai thing right well i
thought my last challenge was get
something from an anime
that the boys haven't watched okay
and what better than an anime that isn't
even out yet because there's no possible
way you could have watched it
oh
nice
arc nights and i i was i was running
around the store and i thought there was
a few hasn't it been
yeah it's been announced announced yeah
and you haven't watched it we haven't
watched it
no one's seen it nobody's seen it except
for the people working on it so i
thought perfect and and you know me and
joey like arc knights i do i still play
it
i don't play it you didn't get the chin
one though
see i i went for the more expensive one
uh okay but the children was i know you
like that i i like chen more yeah why is
the four star no she is she is five
stars she's literally the first unit you
get yeah she's she's kind of repeating
she's yeah yeah she's literally the
default unit yeah i don't even know how
to open her her like final e2 is like
obvious [ __ ]
yeah i'm sorry if you don't play arc
knights yeah well so this is the main
character from arc knights i'm guessing
she'll be in the anime as well i think
she'll be the main goal in the app yeah
um yeah that's so nice though because i
have uh i've seen the nendoroids of army
i don't like nendoroids
i like nanderoids but i i really like
the nendoroids for armia but like a full
figurine of that i actually might
i actually might go and buy this
like it's actually it's actually so nice
if there's one thing arc knights does
absolutely amazingly it's character
design yeah yeah i think i think there
is there is no better game that can do
better character design and it's [ __ ]
so cool
like i've been looking i've been eyeing
up some arc night figures that haven't
been released yet yeah um like
the e3 one that's coming out looks
[ __ ] amazing
yeah it's coming out next year oh i i
remember it for being super open yeah
yeah yeah yeah
she's still open she's still open
well that's that's the arc okay that's
actually so cool i love that oh yeah
army is so cute dude
yeah well that's that was 150 bucks nice
uh i thought you know it's completely a
challenge and it's a pretty good figure
yeah so what was your challenge again oh
yeah
you haven't seen it
uh i haven't yet unfortunately cut
scenes in the game
i see the advertisements on the train
all the time
yeah there you go i thought it was a
cool thing yeah no complaints uh that's
a nice figure
all right all right
one more point for me yeah so i've got
one more figure and of course amiami has
like a really good selection of hentai
and lude figures right yes so i wanted
to get a hentai figure and i found the
weirdest hentai figure i've ever seen
okay bet okay
so
so
on the front it looks like a normal
hentai figure right but the figure
is just an ass
i'm gonna have to blow that
it's literally just an oh this is like
the this is like the way they get sucked
into a wall right right stuck in the
wall you only get half the figure so
it's just the ass can't how are we going
to display this i love that
oh my i love this so much it's amazing
but we can't show it god how much
oh god it comes with uh it comes with it
comes with a it's an art book what the
[ __ ]
the history of it
oh all right all of this luckily i have
these
things covering me
but uh oh actually no it's it's actually
quite wholesome
yeah see this oh maybe not i'm gonna i'm
gonna have to uh i'm gonna have to
oh it's all of that box for that
wait for that it's just an ass okay this
is actually quite wholesome there's like
some there's like some nice artwork in
here what's the point of the artwork i
think it's uh the artwork done by the
same guy maybe who designed this figure
or designed this character that the
figure is based off of i mean the cover
is like wow
yeah we can't show that and the the back
of the book i guess that's fine but uh
yeah the front is wow look at god's ava
whoa
how much was that ever again gotten
oh yeah it's getting gasoline holy [ __ ]
look at that ava it's getting filled up
here i've got room on my place i'll just
put it here i can't i don't know which
one the ava is i bought oh the ava one
is so cool
or maybe don't hold it like that yeah
that's the look at that look at that
it's getting filled up
[ __ ] yeah oh bro that's pretty sick
that's actually so sick all right enough
about the ava
what can you say
what can you say
that's just that [ __ ]
that's actually [ __ ]
i love this why why would you want that
just you know
it's just dumb wait is there like a wall
attachment you can put on i think you
can put it on like your phone
you can do that
um this was
i believe uh 130 dollars
i would
i would i would i happily would buy that
for 130. if it was over 150 i'd have
been like it's just
that is one of the best things i've ever
seen in my life
all right boys how much did you spend in
amiami total
i spent an army army
one thousand and seventeen dollars gone
how much did you spend uh one thousand
i spent a total of 1
580 holy crap at miami jesus holy [ __ ]
well mostly it was on that right yeah
well it was like 800 on a yeah [ __ ]
hell so yeah and you lost two points for
it
but it was worth it because that was
worth it
right i was thinking
the bike is probably gonna be the most
visibly like striking on the thing
because yeah none of this [ __ ] can fit
on the desk
or there
i don't know i don't know you can fit
this thing
we can't show that
it's so funny
let's go to the next store all right but
last and certainly not least is the
final store mandarake yep it's brand new
i i think we tried to go to mandaraki
last year we just didn't have enough
time to get yeah this year we finally
got it it is an absolute [ __ ]
smorgasbord of just random
shimorgas board of random [ __ ] in there
yeah i was like really excited to go to
mandarake because like we always when we
go to akihabara or anywhere on mandarake
is we always got to hit up that store
because it's literally a lottery because
you never know what you can find you can
find some of the coolest [ __ ] and then
sometimes you go on the ship you go
there and you find some of the dumbest
[ __ ] right so it was like how did you
guys feel going into mandarake do you
feel like you had enough budget uh i had
more than enough budget in fact i had to
make sure i got as close to three three
three three as possible in mandaraki
which is like
[ __ ] impossible yeah i have like 500
bucks left yeah oh really yeah i had
like nothing left i had like 500 bucks
just to meet the criteria i mean you did
spend a [ __ ] on it i had to go to i mean
actually take stuff out oh that i could
was able to spend five hundred dollars
at mondragon oh [ __ ] yeah okay i still
wanted to get quite a lot of things yeah
yeah uh let's go uh what was it so we
had one challenge for monday yeah mine
was to buy a figure from a show that
you'd all watched mine was to buy a fate
figure that gantt hasn't pulled for
or doesn't have yeah
uh mine was to
uh ask the store clerk for an
recommendation recommendation
um yeah i'm just gonna lose a point
right away yeah
how many do you how many deals
do you have i'm not gonna lie i totally
forgot that we were doing duplicate
characters i thought it was only
duplicate figures no no no that's extra
extra we've learned the hard way about
duplicate characters and figures how
many points have you lost well i i lost
two points now to dx yeah he has because
he has four drops so i've lost wait does
he have four diodes yeah he bought three
at a stop yeah does does the deal and uh
does dio and jonathan one count yeah
that's still d all right would it count
i mean it's like a duo i don't know no
no no dio's there
zio is clearly there it's not like the
spirit of deals so i've lost a total of
two points because of my do buying
obsession because your love for deer
well the reason i actually bought this
one was because i wanted to get as close
as possible uh to the uh number and this
is one of them that i chose again i
totally forgot about um the
the duplicate the duplicate thing yeah
yeah i ended up buying this but i mean
there's a lot to keep track of but i
also got very very close to the uh three
thousand three hundred and thirty three
okay nice nice all right so my one uh
was
that i had to buy a fgo character that
god doesn't have on fgo
now uh
i'm not gonna lie it's been way too long
since uh i played fgo myself
yeah so tell me your thought process on
this because like my thought process was
okay i knew all of the basic characters
that you get at fgr yeah like the ones
that are just like guaranteed so those
were cl obviously out of the window yeah
okay i thought all right i i talked
about it with knobby my cameraman yeah
he was like an fgo expert and we
basically made it yeah we we basically
like did a hypothesis on what might he
not have i feel like you were really
lucky getting nabi as a cameraman
because if conor got it yeah he would
have been he would have [ __ ]
he would have just had to pick the fake
character yeah so i i had the choice
because i wanted to get as close to
three three through three as possible
yeah i had the choice to either buy a
shitload of fate nenderoids
[Laughter]
and just hope just hope that you don't
have one of them right or
i just go big and go hard on one figure
to get as close as possible i hope you
went big and went harder i went big and
went higher okay what did you get
so
i have i have a backup so i i bought two
fake ones okay okay so the first one i
bought because i'm not too confident
right do you have
ishtar
i got spaceshi
no archer archer ishtar do you have
archer ishtar ah so you have the
character ishtar i'd say you have ishtar
it's it's it's different it's like the
goku black [ __ ] again no no no no no no
no no no
it's very different in fgo it's very
different okay but that's okay that's
okay you can think about that because i
have enough
okay
do you have
gray
no yes let's go
hell yeah navi oh my god okay because
this was the big gamble for me because i
was like i found gray in the [ __ ]
corner like the back corner the [ __ ] is
that what is he what is he the grey is
like the like a grim reaper uh what
class is it uh zep rails airplane
nothing no i think she's uh i have to
check i think yeah i think it's a saber
the saber i think it's a safe [ __ ] you
now
yeah i did not know
wait wait is gray released on
us fake go servers i i yeah the event
was up yeah the event came out recently
oh okay oh no
i mean i wouldn't have pulled for gray
anyway so
i saw this and i looked at na'bi and i
was like this is a recent character
isn't it he was like yes and i'm like he
hasn't been playing that heavily
recently so there might be a chance but
i was so scared because this cost 160
dollars right so i was like i have to go
like all balls no brain on this can we
get this out of the box can uh yeah
let's get this out of the box because
this is actually a really nice feature
oh assassin okay
okay but that's i mean great gray is not
even from like the mainline fate series
no no no
who is from the main i know i don't want
to know that
here we
account just give go your [ __ ] i
secured the point i secured the point
add a point on to me baby all right i
had a po i had a point on for joey he
deserves although yeah although he had
like the biggest cheat sheet of all time
i might imagine having navi as a chichi
for
that for that challenge yeah what would
you have done if you got that challenge
corner i bought a saber figure or
something
do you own saber
i actually don't not the main lightsaber
oh really yeah yeah oh wow
the the only good character from fate is
uh alexander the the the great the chad
alexander
yeah i like i remember the characters
from faith in terms of designs i really
like ishtar so that's why
also ishtar is like a rin face so i'm
just like anytime there's a rin face for
sale i know i know you
please buy another dio figure go ahead
go ahead go ahead and watch your figures
if you like okay okay okay not dios
though show us one of yours um so first
thing i bought was a nico robin one this
was the
this was the recommended one from the
store clerk oh really
because you could have recommended a
little more expensive
this is i mean i i did tell him i did
tell him you know price price is an
issue and he was just like um so you
asked the store clerk for a
recommendation what does he recommend he
goes do you like one piece
and i'm just like okay you're doing
you're doing it you're like a pleb
did you
yeah i'm like i guess you're just doing
your job how you literally picked the
least like inoffensive
franchise you could go for at least he
picked like you know post time skip
robin right at least it's probably
probably
robin
the funny thing is uh so this was like
one of the first figures i got at the
store
um so obviously with with a random guy
asking him asking him for a
recommendation you know i get it as a
store clerk you don't want to you don't
want to go crazy yeah you don't want to
seem too weird yeah you know you don't
want to seem too like when you ask the
waiter for a wine recommendation he you
know you know if he uh you know offers
you the most expensive oh wait i got him
yeah he's not going to go for like the
fancy no no he's going to do it for like
a medium one yeah yeah yeah yeah um so
afterwards uh at the end when i had to
like buy another figure uh his station
was actually next to the hentai figures
section
of course
and i'm sure sydney was frothing at the
mouth yeah and when he saw us uh when he
saw
that uh
when he saw that hentai figures were an
option yeah and that sydney was like
choosing a hentai figure he was just
like oh those were options
i could have picked one of those
oh why didn't you tell me
he went for literally the plebiest
if you ask a staff for recommendation
he's like yeah the one with absolutely
gargantuan tits and like vagina he's
you're going to be like uh what yeah
because i will say out of all the
one-piece figures he did like he did
like pick the most cultured one he
possibly could that is true robin is
probably the most voluptuous one yeah
it's just a normal looking one piece for
you yeah it doesn't look like anything
exceptional
i mean compared to like getting like one
of the male characters yeah
you know if it was like a standard zorro
or like sanji character then it would
have been like i like wrong yeah there's
like a mcdonald's toy
dude i'd go to mcdonald's every day
did you give me if we got this for happy
meal i'd be [ __ ] i'd be very happy
i'd be like mom we're getting mcdonald's
once again
here's the great figure right here okay
that's a big ass scythe look at that
i've already seen grey and like lord
elmaloy's case files um which i believe
is the spin-off oh that sounds pretty
sick yeah yeah it's very cool it's
visually appealing yeah yeah i'm pretty
happy with it and god doesn't have it
it's a it's another saber face it's
another savage yet another saber face
how do i get this [ __ ] plastic off
you just have to rip the plastic i think
oh never mind there we go well all right
i will say i am glad that you didn't buy
a saber figure yeah because i bought a
saber figure really wait connor you
bought a fate figure
wait hold on a second hold the phone
does that mean you guys lose a point
because he has the beast
hold up for us hold up a second
bro
oh ashley you okay actually okay
um so i didn't know this but apparently
he definitely did pick a culture duh
what the [ __ ] should where's the g
string
oh now we all know who my favorite
one-piece character is
god damn okay all right robin i see you
i don't remember that in the uh anime
okay hold on a second question time
you bought a saber
you have the big saber you bought a
russian bun does that count
nah
i don't know what what do you think
connor i thought you you bought uh a
sabre of the [ __ ] or something i don't
know
it's literally the exact same it is
actually
broke off oh [ __ ] i just don't break off
where did this come from connor what
have you done what you've done to your
fate figure i don't know oh i already
actually just broke oh my god i think
you'll lose a point just for that to be
honest
i mean it doesn't matter because you
both bought sabers so you lose a point
all right
so take a point off why did you buy a
sabre gone why did you do it you didn't
think he was going to buy a saber no i
didn't you didn't think you didn't think
i was going to buy a fate yeah that's
why that's why i was that's why when i
got the [ __ ] like buy a fate
character that god doesn't have i was
sweating my ass off because i'm like i'm
definitely going to lose a point because
he's probably bought all the [ __ ]
fake characters
okay wait where did i put this how do i
mount this
just on that right no
if you want to figure this out for me
that'd be great please give me the story
yeah so actually you know i have watched
fate as much as i mean that i hate it i
i just hate it because god talks about
it so god damn much wait this should be
a like a stand
like a long thing uh maybe it's in the
box or something i don't know well
that's that's a good saber figure
actually
this broke off one of the things i don't
know why it's very flimsy oh it's it's
it's oh it's a little end here yeah i
mean i mean uh if you weren't careful
with that which uh you definitely
weren't gonna look careful with it yeah
maybe let's see so i guess another point
oh my god i'm losing so many points
connor's like kind of gaining points and
then just losing them just as quickly
did you guys help did you take a point
off guard in connor yeah okay all right
so that that's actually a good fate for
you i like the one that's really nice
that that is a very nice sabre figure i
think it wasn't that i'll
god it's nothing but fate here look at
that it's god's dreamland right here i
know right
gray and saber
wait i woke up on a podcast where people
bought face uh fate figures and none of
them were bought by me what the [ __ ]
going on how much do you think this cost
this one yeah
200 interesting it's about 200 right 100
bucks oh wow wow be good for 100 bucks
yeah not bad at all yeah so yeah like i
said i mean on the whole fake [ __ ] but i
like re-zero
phase zero a lot
that's a freudian
i do like roushira
i like i like unlimited blade works and
i like fake zero should watch heaven's
feel as well you're here
you've no no no me you've literally
ruined fate for me i actually can't
watch it
all right uh what else did you guys buy
how many more
i've got one more
i know what you've got left i saw you
[ __ ] ask for it
so i so one thing that i think is
underrepresented on trash taste is mecca
and
um so i bought a 400 mech transformer
well we will go evacuate too
i don't think so i i really hope not is
it a building one
i'm [ __ ] buy a building open it up
okay
we're gonna we're
it's like perfectly flat of course
there's no way it would fit in there no
because i've seen i've seen this like
this i've seen i've seen the gunpla and
normally like if it's a building one the
back has you should lose the backers
i just assume all gundam ones are just
the gun plus
if this yeah because because i i've
already wanted a gundam um that wasn't a
gunpla but it was impossible to find and
uh yeah i have i haven't actually seen
gundam pathway yet but alan will not
shut up about it
allen is my editor and he's just like
gone and the biggest gundam simply you
know he's allen's like gone if you do
anything uh just watch gundam hathaway
because actually no it is already no
okay
wow look at that so alan i hope i've
made you proud by uh buying a gundam and
it's actually really nice apparently
gundam hathaway isn't that a transformer
according to the bbc yeah
all right you were at the bbc yeah
this is this is there's so many parts
this is
look look this this is this is like a
pre-built gun plot this is this is
baby's first gun maybe the guys can
build it off camera very fast
yeah um so alan just told me to tell
people to watch gun and hathaway um
that's all i know i've heard very good
things i've actually like legit i've
heard so many good things about gundam
hathaway
um
so yeah we finally have a mecca apart
from you guys you've heard of the foot
but have you heard of the hand
that's it how many jojo figures did you
buy one more actually oh my god
i bought crazy diamond too okay
you know what i respect that i like what
i like i like crazy how many fake
figures did you buy [ __ ] off guard don't
i actually only bought two but there
were like two ones that built the
[ __ ] banks there were like two high
quality figures i go for high quality
what are you saying what are you
insinuating
i go for quality it's all right connor
i'm here to help you with that jojo
collection
is this is this what is this this is my
most expensive figure i bought i saw
this figure pet shop and horace oh my
god uh
how much did this cost would you like to
know yes i know how much it cost and
joey vastly overpaid for it i did vastly
overpay for it but that's all right
because this is going to be that's not
the point that's not that's not the
point
the point can go on the [ __ ] at least
this can go on the shelf
i paid how much did you pay for it i
paid 990 for this
so i better [ __ ] win the most
expensive figure i swear to god i would
like to remind people this is
valued at
dollars
how did it get how did you pay 990 for
this i don't know but this was the only
way i was gonna make do with my budget
uh so yeah i got it and you know what i
ain't even mad because i really like pet
shop and horus
you're right you're right joey but uh
who who's the real winner here i think
it's mandarake yeah you know what i love
mondragon i go there often they made it
a little christmas present to you man
300 profit you made a 300 profit off of
me i hope you're
happy um i let sydney choose a figure so
of course oh that's going to be a big
mistake oh yeah of course of course
yeah i don't know if i can show this is
that do i want to get this one out huh
what from
oh i thought
this open because i don't think we can
show it when buying hentai figures there
are so many hentai figures that come in
boxes that uh are just blank they don't
contain a picture at all so it's kind of
a gamble to see what kind of figure
you're gonna get um so i'm about to find
out now
okay no that's that's her nips alright
that's the ass and argue yeah so that's
the other [ __ ] yeah so
sydney straight away recognize the
asanagi figure
um i'm gonna keep this
yeah keep it in the plastic yeah
that's really nice though
trying to show the patrons
yes okay patreon okay okay i think i
think patrons deserve the equality that
is asanagi he's my favorite hentai
artist this is actually a pretty good
figure yeah
it's a really nice figure yeah oh wow
yeah
why is your teddy bear being bondaged i
don't know because it's arsenal dude
what he's into some kinky [ __ ] what what
is this is this a replaceable ass
what is that it's goku
it's it's black goku it's black coco
wait wait wait wait can you choose the
thickness that she's going to be here
you can
what the [ __ ]
dude this is next level hentai figures
man okay here's my uh here's my hold it
up hold it up for the main i mean okay
don't get me wrong it looks amazing yeah
it's not a thousand dollars it's not a
thousand dollars it's probably very rare
i've never seen it before i've never
seen it before so i'm guessing that's
why it costs so much yeah i mean it's
sick and it can go on the shelf thank
god yeah exactly it's not too big it's
not too big the basement
as well
what it can go on the shelf okay okay
okay some of some of my all of mine can
go in the shelf we just need some
we just need some like black tape we can
do like uh canonically censored um
canonically censored i realized this
part
oh [ __ ] yeah what happened yeah oh no it
came it happened when i took it out of
the bag oh [ __ ] that's all right we can
we can bond it
imagine if you paid 990
no i do remember it saying that this was
uh broken in one point this was broken
in one part
oh my gosh that must be like that's an
easy thing that must be like super rare
yeah that's an easy fix uh
what else do you get what else you got
[ __ ] that nesco
don't tell me you got one as well go on
uh i just remembered i just bought some
other [ __ ] there's a naruto teddy bear
oh a kakashi teddy takashi teddy bear oh
he's my favorite fortnite character dude
yeah some some stuff i bought just to
pad out the number just to get as close
to uh yeah it's a question how much did
you guys do like
small scale adjustments to get to the
phone okay so the the difficult thing
about mandarake
is that
some price tags had tax on it and some
price tags didn't right so trying to
calculate if the price you were getting
was actually like with tax or without
tax was like [ __ ] insane see because
i
just completely coincidentally i thought
i was gonna have to do that when i
bought my three figures yeah but then
when i calculated everything
i literally couldn't it was that it was
that close i really yeah i actually like
completely coincidentally i got insanely
close to three three three three i hope
as closer
than you two what's your cheapest figure
by the way gone
the pikachu because i've got an even
cheaper one have you actually 100 yen no
[ __ ] way oh you just lost the point
there you've lost another point i lost a
point to gain a point
i thought for sure the pikachu would
have lost him a point i i was so
confident that i would get the exact
amount that i had well no no he yeah he
hasn't what what was i bought for 100
yen so what was 200 no but what was that
bought for what challenge nothing
it was it was so that he could get as
close to all right uh um don't add a
point yeah it's it's whether he gets
close to the number enough do you like
out of mastercard um you're almost sure
sure
there you go you can have that one
this is going in the background corner
no it's not going anywhere
is that what you bought
uh i bought one more thing buy a figure
from a show that you'd all watched all
right that was a challenge right
nice ah okay well you know what i i i
like it because you've bought you've
you've completed uh you've completed
this uh the code geass journey and
you've now found a mate for c2 which you
bought last night exactly right it's
perfect yeah so i can open this up let's
have a look i ain't even mad with this
one so this one's great that's a clean
win that's a clean thing i see nothing
but dubs here yeah that is a dog so give
me a point back
you added one back
yeah wow
is that everything you bought joey
that's everything i only bought three
things
oh yeah because like the thing about
mandarin okay the [ __ ] horror one was
a thousand dollars
i had to use my budget somehow that's
true
i think the biggest the biggest
difference between this figure special
and the last figure special is that i
was like i was like struggling to find
things to like fit the budget that we
had set yeah because
like we could have in most of the stores
we could have bought like the most
expensive figure there and a lot of
times we did buy the most expensive
figure there uh within reason yeah oh
that looks good that's a nice straight
up
clean fit oh
it connects
i have one more thing okay but connor i
think me and you are going to need to
swap uh because i i'm going to need i'm
going to need the table for this uh
conor can we swap for a second why don't
you put it there huh
also i want both your reactions at the
same time okay
okay
all right so i've got one more surprise
um it's a bit it's a bit uh out of the
box okay literally yeah you're telling
me i could see it
what the [ __ ]
so
um that's the size of my girlfriend so i
was struggling to like fill up my budget
right and
mandarake had a lot of cool figures but
nothing that really like not nothing
that really likes you know spoke to me
yeah
um and then i was thinking uh if you've
got another fake figure i'm gonna
[ __ ] kiss
don't uh don't guess what this is yet
right so should we close our eyes i'm
gonna close my eyes
i swear to god god if it's another fake
one
i'm so excited okay okay is this what it
feels like to be a small child during
christmas
you know what
i'm hearing a lot of uh struggling
oh okay so before you open your eyes i
just want i just i just want to uh
put a bit of back story to this okay it
better be quick okay
so
um we like to [ __ ] on america a lot as
you know trash tastes part of trash
taste is [ __ ] on american culture
yeah okay
and so i thought instead of [ __ ] on
american culture for once why not
embrace it
okay
[ __ ] hell what was that what was that
that's okay
[ __ ] steal brick and so i thought we
can embrace american culture together
for trash taste okay so you boys can
open your eyes
what the [ __ ] god
what the [ __ ]
okay um so this is an airsoft gun
um but
i did not know that airsoft guns look
like this
this is
a steel brick do you want to feel this
what the [ __ ]
oh my god if if police come they're
going to arrest us that
are we going to get demolished oh my god
so for obvious reasons i'm not going to
put get out of the box yeah because this
looks way too realistic how much was
this
this was only 300 bucks
i like this is this is making me wonder
what the airsoft community is like in
japan
because this is
well if a zombie apocalypse happens i
know who i'm going to
like this is the closest thing
oh okay
yeah yeah yeah of course of course of
course uh this is not going out of the
box uh just in case anyone ever thinks
that this is anything but an airsoft gun
but uh youtube this is an airsoft gun
don't worry about it i think we might
have to blur it for you we'll probably
have to blur for youtube patrons
there you go enjoy uh
enjoy that and so yeah this is uh so
yeah i was like you know what
americans love gun so let's just buy a
gun
[Laughter]
americans what do you think how
realistic does this video because yeah
could you have sounded more like a
neanderthal america love gun america
but if you [ __ ] bought this
i can't believe god you didn't realize
the whole point of this
challenge was the five figures for the
background of our set no i wanted to buy
[ __ ] to see your reaction i thought that
was the whole point of the thing of the
challenge
i wanted to get a good reaction out of
it oh you got a reaction where do we put
this i don't know
about the other figures but actually
where do we put this we can put this how
do we get rid of this without someone
calling the police
we can figure that out later yeah let's
figure that out later
change to me
hello we've had a time skip no [ __ ] if
you couldn't notice uh i lost all my
hair from thinking so hard
so we are recorded the previous
recording for so long that we actually
ran out of time uh so we couldn't record
the outro and uh we thought you know we
thought about having some continuity
yeah then joey got his haircut so we
were just like yeah i didn't i didn't
quite think about that
i'm not a team player here
so yeah i guess uh we wanted to i think
the last thing we wanted to do was to
tally up all the points right of all of
the challenges that we were doing yes
and
also do a forfeit as well unfortunately
uh because we recorded for so long i
mean i think the recording's like three
hours long now or something like that
it's a very long episode yeah so
yeah so we rather think about it and we
thought that it would be better if we
tallied up the points on stream and
we're not just going to do that there
are a few points that are under
contention like for example uh is still
angry two weeks later
is uh is the character that joey bought
can can he beat goku is it even goku in
the first place you know how many
characters in a mogus
that was a real contagion they are the
[ __ ] same i'm sure you guys will
agree with me live on the 21st yeah
so what we're going to do is we're going
to do something similar to what we did
for our trash chase awards uh we're
gonna have a bunch of categories some of
them which we argued on this podcast and
some of them are entirely new categories
like who do you guys think bought the
best figure and who do you guys think
bought the worst figure and other things
that we can think of that are going to
contribute to the final score for what
we have and then we will be doing our
forfeit
it's live on stream
live on stream live on stream and well
and i guess like as well we'll also be
able to like show you guys some of the
figures that we couldn't really like
delve upon too much in the episode
otherwise this would have been like a
five hour episode so any things we
missed during this episode you'll be
able to see it live and if you're
watching this episode right now you know
much further in the future then you can
probably check it out on the after dark
channel where we will upload all of our
streams which is down in the description
below so subscribe to that channel as
well yeah so the stream is going to be
on the 21st of december here's the time
at 7 00 pm jst is that right that's
right all right yes god looks like he's
like in a deposition
i did not hit her
i'm just trying my best to like retain
all the information that we agreed on
because we just like started turning on
the cameras and talking and i'm just
like wait a minute we didn't agree on
anything you're developing alzheimer's
mid-sentence the 21st is the day that we
agreed to do the 21st you did sound a
little christopher
uh find out who won who's gonna eat the
punishment yes eat uh because of course
yeah
we actually we actually don't even know
yet either but it's gonna involve a food
and it's not going to be a pleasant
experience yeah i mean joey doesn't want
to eat it yeah the scores that we got
from our individual shops are like on
screen right now i can't even remember
what i got because it's been like a week
since we recorded in a while join us
then we'll see you at the live show what
are you waiting for go and get your
tickets they're free by following us on
after twitter
tickets it's going forwardmaster.com
follow us on the after dark twitch or
just trash tasers it's known on twitch
funny enough no after yeah we'll see you
there we fun and uh we'll find out who
dies also thank you very much to our
patreons
for supporting us and making this figure
video possible yeah honestly if it
wasn't for you guys supporting us we
wouldn't have had um
literally ten times the budget yeah from
one year difference
thank you very much you can see the all
the lovely patrons on screen right now
it's so cool yeah yeah absolutely
absolutely and again if you like this
this guy's gonna vote the fate figure of
all time no
get off the screen
but hey if you like to support the show
then make sure to join our patreon at
patreon.com also follow us on twitter
send us your memes on the subreddit and
if you hate our face listen to us on
spotify maybe not this episode might not
be a very good spotify so but every
other episode listen to us on spotify
and uh yeah guys thanks for tuning in
and we'll see you guys in the live
stream yeah should be fun
[Music]
you